You
Do you hear that do you hear that it's fucking nothing
Wait, I should have done this one. Um, does that sound better?
Does that sound better the the um?
The microphone I fixed it. I fixed it
Hello
I literally just spilled water on myself, and I'm not even like joking and like trying to be cheeky or whatever
I literally I just noticed I didn't close
Oh, I just squirted at me. Um, my little water thing
So I'm soaking wet sounds like I'm underwater. No
It's only I'm gonna keep I don't believe any of you hold on
Hi kitty, what are you doing? I literally
Work so hard to fix this and you're telling me
Oh no, oh my god
Okay, I think there was like a filter on and I don't know why it did that
No, there's no AC shoes
Wait, no, you can hear I literally I was
Messing around for an hour
With my microphone trying to fix it. So if you're telling me you can still hear my AC. I'm gonna cry
I'm literally
Where's my crying tag?
Gonna cry
AC is the main care. No
No, hold on. I don't believe you. Are you guys lying to me? I'm gonna listen to myself for a second
Hello myself, can I talk? Oh
Oh
My headphones are on. Oh
Gosh
You can hear it you guys are liars bitches bitches
Bitches
Stop memeing me stop it be nice. I'm gonna
Oh
Shit fuck where I messed something up. No, that's not what I meant to do
There it is I
Need to change the toggle for this because it makes my whole entire YouTube full screen
Oh
Sounds perfect
It's still there
Okay, no, you know what we're serious
you guys
Don't forget just because I'm a goofy girl failure as some of you like to affectionately call me doesn't mean I
Won't wrap my legs around your head
And squeeze you tightly until your neck pops like a Barbie doll
Hmm, I promise it's not a no. Yeah, it's not a threat. It's a promise
Have any in at all today it's 4 p.m. You know, we're just I'm gonna have a little bit of girl dinner a little bit of early girl dinner
Um
So mom
Go-go squeeze apple cinnamon applesauce
Don't eat a cookie. I know
Can you believe Azura's?
ASMR got taken down when she was way more in tamer than me or
Or in me and honestly, I feel like she was just as tame as Mercy and Mercy's is still up
Thank God. Mine's gone to the ether aka. It's been privated
I'm like tempted to like let's put on private it for like a minute
Oh
Mmm
Yeah, I'm actually the only one that made it out alive
That's because I can't help myself and tease you guys. I
Also, just like I personally really like
mouth sounds
And it is just really annoying
But I'm like I can't even do like mouth sounds or kisses or belated numb numb numb numb
It's trying to you nice. I'm are they I don't know. I haven't looked at her schedules. I
Haven't looked at her. We have a little schedule thing. I have to I haven't looked at it. I
Know that strong. He's playing like avatar
At first when I started on the schedule, I'm like, oh like the last airbender, but no James
I
But yeah, I can't on private the vaude because I will get got
because in me got got and
Azura got got
Honestly, it's only a matter of time before Mercy gets got
So it is what it is
But you know, um, I know that some people are trying to find a way to put together
Like some sort of archiving system if that does happen, I will
Definitely pass that along to you guys or whatever if that's allowed. I don't know manager
Will you do I'm not safe for work non-live on your channel. Well, this is is it's not safe for work. I know I'm like
Big boob duh, but like I'm I'm safe for work. Oh, do you mean like a video video?
Um, I do have like although I know strong. He's worried that I might get taken down or something
Um, I have like a really cute
like snuggle with me audio and then like a meme audio and
So I don't but I don't know if it'll work
Like I don't know if like because YouTube's really cracking down on any sort of mouth sounds
And how the algorithm works an algorithm just the bots work right now is that they're combing through the newest videos
So that's why you'll like see like people with like millions of views
Have like the most foul
ASMR videos, but they're like from like a year ago or so or like a couple months ago
The it's not you it the bots aren't prioritizing the old ones are prioritizing the new stuff. So
Yeah, oh, I just smack my microphone. Sorry
Because I'm gesturing. I need a 3d model so bad. I'm moving around
Um, but yeah in the JP side. Yes, the JP side has been and I also think that's because the bots don't really know how to
Deal with England deal with English the bull they don't but like handle like Japanese and stuff
It's the Mackis again by big girl. Oh
You're so bad
But um, yeah, so that's why we're getting kind of like
Tart and also like people are gonna report us because you know, we're a company that
Although we do safer work on our YouTube channels. They will you know report us. It is what it is
We knew what we were getting into. Oh
That she be calm bum
Pots need to let go
Like I looked up here looking videos and some of them are not yet up and not taken down like the bigger youtuber
Yeah, exactly and it's like another thing like people like oh my god, you guys are getting cold so bad
It's because we're very new that the bots look at our channel and they're like, okay
They don't watch a lot of videos
They don't comment too too much they must be a bot so we're gonna remove some followers
We're gonna and that's what so they've just kind of been
Nuking our stuff and like we probably be over 5k by now
But I feel like when we get monetization
Which is a very phone. We haven't like
Applied it yet. We're just making sure everything's good before then
but when
See I lose my train of thought cuz I'm I'm just a little
But when yeah, so it's just because of the algorithm the bots whatever it's I don't really think
Somebody is like at YouTube sitting at their desk and every time we get a hundred new followers taking away
And I also I don't think YouTube
Much likes
VTubers like twitch as well. So y'all y'all y'all she got that chibits is
Would you believe me if I told you I have not been diagnosed with autism or ADHD, I'm just a quirky gal
John YouTube hates youtubers. Yeah, and if um and I can't add any free stuff to my patreon because if it's 18 plus overall
It can't be
It has to be pay walled like 18 plus stuff has to be pay walled
See and I'm probably gonna try to figure out how to upload like
Maybe I'll do like a Twitter
I'll ask management if I can make like a Twitter that I can upload the VODs to like um
Cut it in half because I know you can upload like two hours. I think to Twitter
So I'm like just in case
Like archive it
Maybe I don't know if it's not sure. I don't know anything about YouTube. I don't I'm sorry
It's only my my six day my six day out here. I don't know what I'm doing
But um
Yeah, fans late, maybe I don't know cuz I don't I don't know how fancy it works either
But yeah, I bet like where I know what we're looking to get more established on other platforms
There are more used and then we'll like I know like a hundred percent at one point want to play like the
Hoony pop like with the
with the you know with the
Yeah, but yeah, who knows have a burner va channel, but that'd be like but that's a thing like if I made a burner va channel
It'll probably just get taken down, especially. Yeah, I just don't I feel like this wouldn't work
I will not touch Twitter even if you pay me unfortunately, but my archival is good archival. Okay
This guy hates Twitter. He hates zitter. What's who?
He doesn't know and he doesn't know whatever
The joke over his head. Um, but yeah, we're gonna play
Hold on me eat some applesauce
Wait, no mouth down
We have to play we have to play we're going to play
Class of 09 I've never played it before I've only watched the trailer in the animated thing which I thought was hilarious
I was laughing hysterically. Um
If you're someone who I'm just gonna say a little disclaimer if you're someone who is sensitive to like
Darker humor and edgy humor and jokes. This might not be the video for you
because um, if you ever saw the anime trailer, there are some
What's that song pumped up kicks jokes
If you catch my drift, maybe pin a disclaimer, that's a good idea
Mm-hmm
Let me just tippy-tappy type
Video game is edgy
If you don't like it go cry elsewhere
Okay, thanks
Also check out my merch
On the market shameless plug
Only 15 no what you you think I'm not done yet you think I'm not done yet
Okay, I need a link
My stomach hurt I wonder why
Probably because I need to eat something I'm like
Craven cheeky tendies in the worst way. I saw our meme about cheeky tendies and I'm like
Oh, I need me some cheeky tendies
Okay, where is my
Hell yeah, brother, I don't even know how to pin something so this will be we'll see how this works
Nobody talk
Okay, I did it because then I wouldn't be able to catch up to it
Oh shit, where did my not no not the viewer count
Oh
Oh, okay. So yeah, you guys voted that you guys want me to do the voices
So I'll do the voices we'll have a girl that kind of looks like me. She's very cute. She's blonde there
We actually have the same exact eye color
You know what I should have done. I should have like prepared
Something where I'm like I cosplay as her
It would have taken way too long to cut off my head from my body again though. That took me like an hour
I have to make my full model transparent for that
Um, she looks like she might be like
Valley girl and the other girl who is like dark hair and blue eyes looks like she might be like, oh my god
I fucking hate it here. So she's probably be closer to my normal voice
Nicole jacka
Jacka and Nicole
It's not it wasn't a technical difficulty how it works to use those little things
Except I did it wrong
Because I can't read Japanese or Chinese. Okay. Ni ha ma leave me alone. Um
So I have to you have to make her the whole so from the neck
Down I had to make my entire model transparent
Do you know how many layers are in a vtuber model guys?
Imagine every shadow every rope every highlight every freaking
My bra my shirt there's stuff under there
Maybe maybe not. Um, my my beautiful necklace. I had to make those all transparent
Hold on. I kind of want to
I used to have a barrel roll redeem on twitch. Oh youtube, please. Can you please set up for deems?
But um, yeah
Oh, hey, I see
What's up to the back flip that wasn't that was like a forward flip
Yeah, champ. It'll be so good. Come on. It'd be perfect. It's so good for audience interaction
Yeah, you know how I do it
I get up
Um for my computer desk and I actually do a cartwheel. That's how it works. I'm not lying to either
Long girls more valley in the black hairs little jersey. Okay. I can do a jersey accent except
When I do a joysy accent
Joyzy joysy joysy joysy
Let's go to joysy
Jersey
I need to listen to like jay wow for a second
Did you get the lug a dwig twitch youtube extension? What's that explain?
Just lowest grip it again
pita
pita there's a hoisin here
That's not jersey what jersey shores in jersey
That's like pure jersey
You know, I start something about jamaica, but you ran away
I can't do jamaican accent if I did with this model people would just
think I was
a very bad person
My lowest it's actually not the only the only sounds good because it's so easy just to go
Pina because you just gotta and make it real nasally in this high pitch
You say way more you say or I sound
mods
Ban him for his grammar. No, I'm kidding. Don't do it. Don't do it mods
Oh
Oh my god, can we just
Can we just talk about how my alt blew up for like real quick?
If you know, you know, that's it. That's all I'm gonna say. Um
My alt twitter it's more than my main twitter now. That's great
Uh grammar bad
I used to be so like my dad was very particular
I like how I was just talking about alt twitter and I want to talk about
Um, my dad was very particular with like how I spoke. Um
and how I um
Like wrote and typed in everything. So I was very much like very anal on grammar
Can I say that? Can I say anal? Was that allowed?
boomi, please
It's like rubbing against my microphone
Um, so I was like very particular
Mods improve his grammar. I just think anytime I was like mods. I just think of that
Shark boy and larva larva larva girl, uh lava girl thing where
Like one kid is like
Mr. Electric send him to the principal at what and I feel like that's where it comes from
Going a mile minute. What do you mean? What do you mean lava girl for gen two? Please you want a bug girl?
Oh, I want a bug girl so bad. I want a bug girl
And she just like lays eggs
in you. No
I don't know. I need like because it's already like, you know, he got modder, which is like a roach. You got you got, um
You got juniper
And I don't I actually don't know what type of bug juniper is. I think she's just like a type of beetle, right?
you know
What the sigma what?
are you
Is that a kid? Who says that?
I'm off. Yes. I don't know why I thought she was a beetle so come out and don't come for me
Um, she's actually gorgeous. I do never if you see this. Um
I like bug girls a lot
Oh wait, no mouth sounds
There's a centipede tuber. Yeah, I'm scared of centipedes, uh, but I saw her model and I'm like, yo
That's pretty sick. I'd watch you just so I could conquer my fear of centipedes
Mom throw him to the lava girl. Oh boomie. You look so cute. I just turned to the side and he's eating in his bed
Oh my little man
I like to watch of a lot of urban rescue ranch
Excuse me and um
Because it's just fun to watch and so I end up like talking like that dude be like, oh
Boomie eating some cat food for today
But like I'm like, that's the goal right there. I just have a rescue ranch just like that
rescue wild animals
Definitely afraid of cockroaches. I'm actually I'm literally
Not afraid of bugs literally only
those house centipedes freaked me out like um, my parents are afraid of bugs
So when I lived at my parents house like my dad's like terrified of slugs
Although that's not really a bug, but anytime there was like a bug
I would have to get it and then my mom's like kill it kill it kill it and I'm just like
Takes this giant stick bug off the side of my house not knowing where it came from because
I don't think stick bugs are native to the area puts it on the another tree outside and my mom's just like
And then spiders I like spiders. I love spiders. Um during covid
During miss rona and her visit to everybody in the whole world. Um, I was my my niche interest was um
snake breeding and uh tarantulas
And so I would just watch a bunch of like tarantulas stuff. Oh roly poly isopods
I love me some isopods isopods are so cute, especially my favorite ones are the ducky ones
Um, I like bugs
I like bugs
I also like oh, we have three tarantulas. Oh my god. I'm gonna step in my cat fee. I didn't even know we were there
Um, I love snakes. I love ball pythons. Uh, I like banana banana morphs. They're so cute or um
Ball pythons are like, yeah r. Ip big outs r. Ip big outs. I wish I could raise my hand to be say r. Ip big outs
um
Jumping spiders. I had a little when I went to the store for the drunk stream
There's a massive, uh, I can't remember the latin name of it
It wasn't the the black jumping spider. It's the more brown one
And she was hanging on the side of my car when I was driving over and I'm like and I was tapping on the window
trying to get her attention when I was stationary, of course and um
I'm like ma'am ma'am. Please let me pick you up so I can put you uh
In a tree or like in these bushes or in this grass and she just wouldn't let me she wouldn't let me pick her up
So I'm like, all right. You're coming with me to the store. So she came to the store
And so she probably would never have traveled that far in her life. So I hope I didn't like
Ruin anything for her and there's also this family of jumping spiders that live on the side of my balcony
It's this big lady and her boyfriend that I'm surprised. She hasn't eaten yet or maybe he's just like hasn't
Gone up to her yet, but I was like watching her. Um
Eda
Eda, I think it was like a fly and I'm like, wow, that's so badass
You look so majestic and then this little tiny tiny boy
Tiny uh boy jumping spider came out. I was just like watching her
Oh, no
No, thank you
I had my desktop audio turned off
Dang it
Because then it messes stuff up because then it like double plays but the thing
I need to like make it. I don't know how to make it. So it's like a separate sound thing for
Alerts so it doesn't just play my desktop because I say
um
I'm something of a gamer myself
God damn you graduate in 2009. Yeah, yeah, I'm I'm old. I'm so old. No, I did not graduate in 2009
Jesus christ. I was I don't even remember how old I was
I was a beach. I
but like honestly
Like I used to be afraid of bugs and my mom got me this bug book
And I would just walk around with little magnifying glass and that like I was it really helps you conquer your fear
Um guys, I'm I did not graduate in 2009 for the love of god. No, I did not graduate that early
I I had still a ways to go very very more much more years
Um, I am not I am I I am a hag
in
theory
But that's just a theory a game theory more like 1909
There's an isopod plush. What? Um, if you were eight when x-men last guys, I was just spitballing
I don't know if I was eight. I just was like, was I eight? I don't know
People are like, all right. So if we triangulate and we carry the x over the y we can find out uh, shebe's exact age
Huh, he who I should just tell you guys just make up something crazy. I'm 56
Yep, that's me my youthful voice. I'm 56. I don't have
A wrinkle on my body. I am so youthful
but uh, so I'm not a hag I'm a
I can't think of a word that would be higher than a hag
I'm a christmas hag
No, that's not because the christmas cake. I don't know
mega
Yeah, guys spread spread that spread that spread that narrative spread the narrative that I'm 56
I'm a granny. I'm a gilf. Yeah, you thought I was a milf. I'm a gilf
I don't have any kids besides my cats, but I'm a gilf. I birthed these cats
um
From my loins actually like that one weird tattoo of that woman who had tattooed her
Kitten versions of her cats on her uterus. So it looked like she was going to give birth to cats
I don't know why anybody would tap that you could google it. I don't know if you want to google that actually don't google that
Hello everybody, I'm a granny. She why am I so far away? Whoa
Hey, how are you doing? I missed you so much. Oh my god
Um, yeah, that's my sorry
That's my patreon voice. I'm sorry. Oh my tommy
Did you see it? Did you see like you said you googled it? Did you find it?
Thank you for the present. You're welcome
Bumi, what are you looking at?
Sometimes Bumi just looks up and I'm like, is there a ghost?
I'm like, please don't
Is she be tendies?
Oh, I'm gonna order door dash
because
I did absolutely nothing this morning besides fix my microphone and fuck about on watching tv and youtube videos and also
um mess around on my alt twitter, so
hello, hello
I'm gonna love this game. I hope so
You're 30 and you dropped out. I'm so sorry
I
Hope you got that g ed bro. Get that g ed educate education. Honestly
If you graduate at least high school, you're fine
In my opinion
like college
You get so much more life experience, you know
Doors Zach's bees
What the what is Zach's bees?
Zach's bees
Near me
Maps
Wow, that's thousands of miles away
The fuck is the Zach's bees yo
What
Last time I you know, it's funny
I
Someone was like, oh, we should order from this place and I remember on stream. I just typed it in and I just
Talked to myself because it was just like
Looking for blah blah blah near blah blah blah redacted and I'm like, oh great
I'm like guys, don't be so bad
Long John's silk
Do those still exist?
I don't want to so colleges and no plus having friends in college helps
I can just ask more books. They read and study through them up around line. Uh, yeah, there's like ways to get free books
Don't tell them. Don't ask me what um
East coast on top
Do you wingland represent?
southern represent
California
I almost said south west what's not represent
Yeah, waffle house. I've always wanted to try a waffle house
My I have my aunt I went to waffle house. Well, I didn't go to waffle house
We were driving by a waffle house and I'm like auntie can we go there and she's just like no
That's where the weird people hang out and I was so bummed. I was so bummed because I only heard good things
raising canes
Honestly, it's like okay
like I I
Finally had some and I'm like
This is it
I'm just gonna stick with Popeyes. I don't like all right
I remember like my dad makes really good fried chicken
I don't know what his recipe is, but he does like panko. Oh, there was just one place
I went to in the south that had
This and I've never and I haven't been able to find it since
they had cornflake
fried chicken
And also a cornflake fried french toast
And it was the most delicious thing
I've ever had
Canes for the other limit. It's good. Your sweet tea is too sweet for me
Can is like, okay, like it's not bad
Uh, it's not bad
Olive garden all garden. Mmm breadsticks. Uh, let me make a little reference to you shoves all the breadsticks in my purse if you know, you know
Excuse me. Oh, I didn't even notice I burped and I literally don't even notice that I burp
Until you guys start reading me in the chat
You know, it's also funny. I don't know why I'm I know I burp when I'm nervous
Because I never I have not burped at all today except when I get on stream
I don't get it
Are you able to taste the diabetes of what?
Oh, America has the worst fast food
Like I wish so like
I'm gluten free and I'm lactose free. Do I hear adhere to those things? I don't
I don't
I don't adhere to those things
But I know in europe
Like my my mom's also gluten free and dairy free
um
and
She went to europe and she was eating bread and i'm like, oh, did you have any reaction?
She's like, no, I was perfectly fine and i'm like god damn in america
Why do we have to have so much process in our food? I saw that strawnee got some american snacks and i'm like, oh, no
There's only like two good things in there
Hold on. I have to I want to look at the picture that she posted just just I can't remember
didi didi didi didi
Um, me me me me me me me me me me sprony. What are you?
scrawny cutles
Straining my cuttles right now
She got flaming hot cheetos. Okay. She got talkies good sour patch. Good. I don't like twizzlers
I don't like peeps. I don't like twinkies. I don't like Babe Ruth bars. I don't like made with dugs milk duds
I don't like kisses. I don't like mce and ikes
The I think she got cream soda gross and dr. Pepper good
But I know I used to not like dr. Pepper and she got jolly ranchers mid and nerds mid like I'm like no
Like I want to drag her to America and be like here here have some other stuff because that's not it my sweet
Twinkies with milk
What insert a look at everyone is like calamity took here I
Know exactly there's like five ingredients one of your peen products
I'm like looks at American product here is like the chemical equation for a nuclear bomb
And I'm sticking it in my stomach
Like hold on. Let's look at my my apple sauce
It doesn't even have anything on it it doesn't even say
Probably cuz I have to get to the oh wait. No, it says
Apple apple puree concentrate
Lemon juice concentrate cinnamon. Okay, that's actually not bad
You go go go squeeze you go girl you go Glenn cocoa. I also like these cuz they're gluten and dairy free
I really should be fully gluten and dairy free cuz I suffer every every time I have a bowl of cereal
But you know, it's worth it. I really like Cheerios. I had a bullet Cheerios yesterday. It was great
I had a bullet Cheerios since I was like 12
Why do you have applesauce next to you cuz I was eating it
Nah, I just like to stick applesauce next to me and just watch it just be like
My celiac, I'm not I
Have really bad inflammation
Got that fibro my algea
yeah, and weirdly enough gluten free and dairy free gluten and
Dairy contribute a lot to inflammation so
Like eating something to do
Frequency if you're 56, are you still breedable? Um, yes, of course hundred percent breedable. Wait, why did I answer that?
without a second thought
I was like, oh, you know, you know
I know I don't worry don't worry guys. I got you I um
Why I'm gonna finish the joke because fuck it
I I I stored my eggs. I I froze them so they can inject them in me and then
Anyway, let's play the game. Wow. Yeah, wow games games
Games
Oh, I can't find my stream awkward you guys don't exist then no chat. Oh, what's happening?
What hold I I'm trying to get rid of this weird chat thing that's going on
What I can't get rid of it
Oh my god
How could this happen to me? What are you doing fear? She's like digging into my blanket that I have wrapped around me
Stream not found retrying now
Can I how the frick do I get rid of it stream not found
Stream not found
You guys hear that good
If I just you uh, I see I see
Uh, yeah, I'm gonna probably get a new overlay because there's a little bubble and not being able to see like a part of the screen is really
grinding my gears
Fiat, can you stop attacking me under the blanket?
Please
Jesus
Jesus Christ
Is Jason born actually when you know what I can now I'm not gonna do that because the chat's not even bothered to be readable
I'm gonna I'm gonna stick
To make this at least somewhat useful I'll stick the alerts
Wait, it's not letting me oh, whatever. I don't who cares just play the game just play the game gb
Oh shit
The cat
All right, um, let's see scene volume. That's fine. That's fine. That's fine
It's funny when a girl tells her story only to be told back that it's unrealistic
Almost as if they're afraid to believe it's real
He's fucking loud in my ears
For everyone who doesn't know my mom's a bitch my dad shot himself my life sucks and my brother's on a watch list
Ayo
Was that bad it was just really standard other girls saying their gym teacher wanted to bang them
Their counselor texting them at three in the morning
I was the only one with a white nationalist photography teacher though, so I guess that's something but here's the problem
Mom won't listen the principal doesn't care and I still have all of senior year to get through
My life's just a game a sick hopeless game
Like I've never really been I think I skipped the first game
How's it wait what I really hope they can help me through that. What do you mean?
This is a sequel
Fuck
No, I want to play the first one. I thought the re-up was like a redone version. Oh my god, do I have to buy the game?
I gotta log out and then I gotta buy them my other account and then I gotta
I am alive
Same characters different stories
No, it would take it would be fine. Oh my god. I'm it
I hate it here
Okay, do you want me to go get the first game?
Or do you just want me to play this game?
I will
Because I do want to play the first game. Okay. I'm gonna hold on
I am the world's worst streamer. I really
Okay, I'm gonna be ventriloquist for just a split second
How could this happen to me?
Scuff cotton bum
No, no, no, no, I I thought I would have gotten the first one
I'm gonna play the first one because I wanted to play the first one
I thought it was the first one just like read. I thought the re-up was just like like they remastered it because I'm weird
Look back at this laugh. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, why am I big? I'm trying to just scroll
Fastest girl boss a girl failure to
Add to cart who might caught continue to payment
Use this card ending in
I agree patches
Perfect
So, uh, how about them Dodgers?
How uh, how a fuck shit, where is it?
It didn't show up. I just bought it. Where'd it go?
How's that sports ball?
444 make a wish everybody, you know, right? Am I right? Am I wrong? I'm always wrong
Let me just restart steam real quick
Let's just let's just look at each other drake or Kendrick Kendrick drake can kiss my booty cheeks
I
Can't
It's not showing up, please
It's showing just regular I just got it. Where is it lovely weather we're having
It's nice weather. Oh, it was like, you know, the sprinkling a little bit. It's fine
I was asked I I was asking for rain though because I love the rain
I love the rain
I think I have to log out of my computer and log into
You
I'm not doing all that
Kill me do it now just end my life
You don't like the summer. Yeah summer's okay. I'm a fall kind of gal
Is there any for 10 days?
Did you piss off god or something you start a plague? What's happening over there?
for 10 days
We have been
Fucking your mother what?
Okay, you know what let's just play the re-up then because that's not working
We persevere
Why does it say I've played this for four hours?
Huh
I
You
Well, sorry gotta move myself over again
Oh, uh, how was she be streamed for 45 minutes she didn't play the game
Oh, this rope is filthy. What are you doing with the climbing rope? Nothing just
Wait, can I not
Is this
If I turn that off will they still talk?
Oh, you're the Girl Scouts. Yeah, we learned how to tie knots to go bats and shit not hang ourselves
We're just assuming a whole lot today, aren't we?
Hey, what's going on? Why is there a rope in here? She was just asking me how to tie a noose and like did you help her?
Should I Nicole are you really trying to kill yourself again?
Yeah, no pick your favorite answer out of those
Why would you help her tie a noose?
I didn't oh my god. I can't right now
What's her problem? What's your problem? We're not even two weeks back yet. You're trying to hang yourself the gem rope
Do you have no idea what I had a witness this morning?
The jeffrey kid was doing cartoon voices for mr. Bouldery and the guy does not I'm telling you to future in Hollywood
Like he wasn't joking. Yeah, so now he just encouraged to go like Alma all day
This is going so fast. I have to like paw. Oh shit. Can I like change the speed?
Oh
Oh, they don't so it is automatic. Okay. You know what? We're just gonna. I'm not voice acting. We're saving my voice
Oh, that's your motive for keeping me alive. Yeah, sure. No problem. So will I see you in science today about that?
Why don't you start me something else?
So will I see you in science today about that?
I like how it's a bottle of pills
Regardless of whatever you say. I'm not showing up to any class with jeffrey for the rest of the week
I exerted all that energy to keep you alive and you're still not to go. You can come with me if you want
Uh, I'm just balling the crap out of me after I graduate fine. Go to science and let jeffrey do elmo voice at you
Oh god, are you even going? Yeah, the video is great. The game's quiet. Okay. Yep. All right
Let's go to the mall
Why did we come here if we don't even know what we want to buy
Dude, we're literally in the mall. Just figure it out. Even if I do want something. It's just torture
I have like no money. Who said we're buying anything. Just steal the shit. Oh, okay
You think they have MSI stuff here. I'm sorry I mentioned
Yeah, they're all in my shuffle and they might be in town
I love it. She's me
No, I'm just surprised you like MSI because you're so
Normal
Oh
Never mind. Okay. So what do we get? I want a cd. I'm a self-indulgence great band. Why can't we steal both?
She won't steal twice in the same trip. The only people here is us and some dad buying sketches
Like how they spelt sketches wrong probably on purpose
You wouldn't look at us. We're like children. I know sidekicks are so cool. I used to want one so bad
You know when I was 56
Um
I'm stealing her should I steal a shirt? Oh, I just want to this is so funny. Um
Should I steal a $10 shirt or still a cd?
Where iPods around in 2008 because then I would just pirate it
I'm stealing a shirt
Steal the seat well too bad
You wouldn't download you wouldn't download a car
Sludge lord this looks like
Either Spencers or hot topic
Like
I don't know the tv said you suck. So fuck you. Yeah, right
You guys get paid eight an hour to go to that bitch idiot school. He gets paid eight an hour. Oh, that's true
That would impress us. Yeah, you're dumb white and bro. I applaud five the i4 were out. Okay, bitch
Hey, whoa, where's your manager? Oh wait, I didn't notice it was a hot topic shirt
God damn it fine. Sorry
Good now what sizes do you have msi shirts in right now?
You know the thing is you don't talk to the staff when you go to steal something right because then they're just like they
They know you out is what we have, dude
If you don't check right now, I'm gonna tell your manager. You didn't say hi to us when we walked in
Fuck fine. Joe. Go to your bitches. I'm just gonna go back and pretend to look
Okay, grab the small let's go. Yeah, I was like, how the fuck do you think I'm a large come on
Well, you got big titties. How'd you learn how to do that?
What do you mean learn you can't just take the shit in front of them. Okay, it's like it's like that's just a common sense
Before we get caught. We can't leave now. That was the sound experience. I actually
Cannot comment on that
You know when I was younger, why would you risk getting caught one time?
Oh my god, they talk so fast. I can't even one time. Um
When I was younger
I stole candy
He he
But like one of those like penny candies at like the grocery store
And my dad I was like five and my dad like made me like
Walk back
because he I knew
I took something you probably just saw me do it
And then he's just like and I was like acting really sus
And then my dad made me walk back and apologize to the manager in return the candy
It was literally like
Awerthers like an individually wrapped like werthers and like jolly ranchers
1970 yeah 1975 that's why I call it penny candy. Exactly
So, yeah, it was he stole tic-tacs
Oh my god tic-tacs or tic-tacs still around. I don't even know
Or with the free samples lady chase after us literally anywhere, but here come on
Oh
Little diner
This suspiciously looks like a diner. I know
Where does this take place it's literally just a burger or maybe every all diners just look the same I guess
Someone who butters margarine with butter
You think we got trody fired today. I don't know
I don't care either weird most of our friends just get jobs to buy Adderall
but he has to like
Support himself just to buy Adderall almost like he has to deal with the consequences of his actions or something
Since when do you of all people worry about accountability? I don't worry about it for my actions. I'm too smart for consequences
It's the one time I feel kind of bad for a guy because he can't do any of the stupid money jobs
Well, he could pole dance. There's nothing stopping him from pole dancing
Though I feel ripped off because I learned how to read from nothing
What if you're too shy and just work out hopes in Los Angeles? Okay hooters is even worse than a club
It's a legalized brothel. What how how do you know this? Is it really worse at one?
She says half the girls blow dudes for like $300 tips. Oh my god. My funny story at Hooters
I have to ask her if that actually happened. That's really specific. That really happens. So what's next?
I think although she got she did make major tips working at Hooters. She has big old knockers too
I'd rather do that than end up the dick-sucking girl at Hooters
You can just say girl at Hooters the dick-sucking is implied
Check please. You're not even paying for it. Just get up and leave. Just dine and dash. Oh my god. They are the worst
There's so much happening. I can't even react properly. You don't know the half of it
Not even a quarter for being honest. Well, the sign and sheet is on the desk the unexcused column
Oh, so we just ended up skipping a school to go to the mall to steal shit and get stuff. Okay. That's cool
Yeah, trauma has to be one of the excused hardies, right? For some reason I don't believe you
But today I think that's your problem. It's being a fucking bitch your problem. Ayo, excuse me. Oh my god. It was the trauma
I'm so sorry. So why don't you both enlighten me to the source of this trauma that's caused absence after absence
Uh lie, but no we're gonna we're gonna pull the depression card
There's a game only on them. I don't know
Because it only gives me the display and the
Volume so I'm like, uh, can I because if I could slow it down
That'd be great
Can I just save? Oh
Just lie about having aids
How do I go back? Hello. Oh my god
Let's see. Oh
Actually, I won't keep lying
Okay, yeah, I'll play this one for now, but next I'm done because I actually do want to play the first game and voice it so
There's I don't think there's any way
For me to not make it just auto play hardcore. No, it's just
We were both like, uh, what she said like I can skip ahead
Honestly, I don't know. It's just
We were both diagnosed with manic depression and it's just hard to show up. Oh my god, sis relatable
She said it just nothing makes me happy anymore. Not even cocaine. Not even cocaine
Is that why she's so skinny? Hmm. I'm not sure we've had that as an excuse before but it's totally real
Come on. Isn't it manic depression real? That's like a combination of bipolar and being depressed
She could have said seasonal depression
When he Houston said we need a whole year that was for black history month. No, it was for mental health
Yeah, maybe they're black. They look black to me anymore. They're just really light skin
I just don't feel feelings or care about anything headed into a downward spiral. Oh my god
Automotive only is a game feature kill myself. Oh, that's good. Yeah, and I'm totally numb to hearing that because of my
Manic depression. All right fine. I'll excuse it this time
But I expect you to seek help if this really is so much. Oh, yeah, a comedian hour
You made my day just a little bit better. I have no
I have no emotion in your way of depression. Remember? I think so. You didn't do shit with Lynn. All right
I think instead of class you should head over to your counselor for additional. I would love to voice in a game like this
Hey, uh principle in you got a minute. Hold on. He just slides in. I thought you dropped out
Well, yeah, I did but I think I want to reenroll what the hell great to hear trody
Why the sudden change of plans? I think it just make going to college a little easier
Also, I got fired from hot topic. They said I let someone steal a shirt. Oh my god. They got a fire
What why do you say that they were in the mall like two hours ago? No
He fucked us
Could you step outside for a bit? Yeah, no problem. I meant trody
Oh, no, we were fucked. Yeah, who can trust what they say manic depression, huh?
Suicidal thoughts and all we had retail therapy right now. So we're not all the way lying. Exactly
Worth it for a t-shirt at the mall. You must be so
Yes, I'm self destructive. Why do you think I'm stealing t-shirts? It's a cry for help
Dude, can we just go to an easier book this is the easier book
Is everyone in the reading buddies program this stupid? Hey, the principal sent you here to help me
So make good or I'm snitching hard. Okay. Kylar. What are these names? Surf and Co's. Let's be like amber conby
Oh my god, bin Laden
Who has fucked you raw?
two
Fist uh, oh my gosh, hard one on purpose. It's a dr. Seuss book. You fucking did he cannot be this dumb
If it's so easy, why don't you try it, huh? One fish two fish redfish you bitch
Blue fish. See, I knew you couldn't do it. This is a really potent punishment. No, I want to drop out
For real, let's go to here. Let's go to Hooters get some tips. I don't think they will I think you have to be at to work at Hooters though
It's senior year. You're not. Oh my god. She's like very seen haircut. I'm not either, but you sound like a sitcom
Here we go again. I feel like I'm just reacting to a tv. So this is just a watch along at this point
I'm like, where the hell did you get so much at all? My boyfriend's 25. I can get whatever
Her boyfriend's 25? Sweetie. You're being groomed
Eight year age gap. That's pretty cool. That should work out. Yeah
The irony in her voice start giving out free syringes at south county south county high school
Uh-huh before they were trying to curb the opioid addiction
But now they're just trying to keep all the kids from getting hapsi or whatever because I could like remove their voices
I would just be speaking really fast
Socks
Oh, do you do that? She shoots up my boyfriend got me into it, but it's just lines
Not just nothing serious your boyfriend dating you in high school got you into heroin
You guys are gonna be awesome. Oh my god. Match made in heaven. What do you want the needles for for him?
Because he did it so much that like eventually doesn't hit. So like he has like track marks in his arms in his feet
It's crazy
What happens to some good holy
Yeah, I'll see you there. I feel pretty educated on stuff because I just been to watch euphoria. So I'm like, uh
Yes, well, yeah, I get references now
Usually when I look in the mirror, all I see is a self-destructive pill popping hoe after five minutes with her
I feel like Selena Gomez
Like you feel Mexican
I have school, Nicole. You'd fuck that school. Shit. So from everything we had to do
Oh, no, I'll make I'll make them go to class euphoria. Um, no, not that euphoria
No, the tv show euphoria. It's a tv show with Zendaya
Okay, let's go to the theater class. Let's go
Crispin here
Emily. Uh-huh. Yeah, watch I was watching euphoria the from face connect
We do it right. Do you want right taking attendance? Nicole tardy. Which one's the teacher tardy in here
Meaning you're late since when are you in charge of that your student like the rest of us? Okay? I was gonna say last week
Not anymore. Ms. Tegan made me student teacher while she's off working on a that's not how that works
I get you a substitute dunking those nuts
Acting sucks. Well, I thought it's just pastes of the board. Well, I don't think you're a good actor either
You probably couldn't even lie to the police. Yeah, honestly, don't take her side. Why not?
She's right because I'm your student. Wait. Why is like Jesus crossed out on his shirt or her shirt?
I really can't tell I ever killed himself while dating you
So anyway, today we'll break up
One'll do a table read exercise. The other will be improvised acting
So who wants to do what I don't want to do anything the teacher isn't even here
I just can't wrap my head around if my teacher's like, sorry, I have to go on and do this thing and this puts a student in charge
Yeah, that's not jesus. Who is that?
Not pretty enough to be in movies. I don't get why you want to act acting isn't about looks
It's about talent and creativity. This is about written character, but you want to see it for a while
Stop calling me ugly. No, I'm not calling you ugly. I am
I am you look like the girl from harry potter, but not photogenic
Go off says
Should do a group improv or table reading
It's too improv. I think they'll be funnier
So how do we do this?
Wait, maybe I can just like let's see if I can read it fast
Let's see if I can read it fast because like I feel like I'm doing nothing
I give you guys a snare. Oh, yeah, it makes sense. So the scene is you're a newlywed husband and wife in 1949
The wife wants to know what the war was like
What if he doesn't know what the war was like
It was 1949 everyone was just getting out of the war at least knew someone, right?
The
Okay, so we go now
Yeah action
Hey, you seem kind of upset. Is there a thing you want to talk about?
Nah, I'm good. Oh, well, do you want to hear about the war?
No
Wait, wait, megans. You can never say no for improv. It just like makes it go nowhere
That was the plan
Well, I guess don't do that. All right, let's try again. Hey wife something on your mind
Yeah, um, there's something I've been wanting to stay lately
Oh, what's that the end?
Oh
Why do you want to say that it's 1949, isn't it tell me if you see
Oh, maybe oh, so let me just
I'm gonna I'm gonna be honest with you
I have the pass so it's fun. I may not vtuber look like I have the pass, but I have the pass
I did mention my dad is proud of my mom this way. So this is like
I
Can't cancel me if I'm brown
I'm getting that tan toggle
Prove it. Well, you'll see it in the the monetization stream
I was like, I'm like, I didn't know I'll be honest with you. I didn't know how people would react if they're like, oh
She's white vtuber, but she's
light-skinned tan
Iro, uh, like I don't really give a shit play who I play. I'm an anime girl on the internet
I have fucking bunny ears like it's whatever
But yes, uh, I wanted you if you were gonna find out anyways when I do a hand cam stream and a
thigh cam. So let's just continue
The n-word is probably
With no repercussions
1949's a great year for me. Uh, I'm glad you're happy. Yeah. Oh, you see that see what that different colored family pulling up in a
Lincoln you want to do the honors
What are the honors calling them the n-word? Duh
Why would I do that? It's 1949. Why wouldn't you all right? Um, is there anything else you want to talk about?
Yeah, you want to
It's not all right now
I can't my
I love this game so far. I love it
I think reading is the best option. Are you kidding me?
And my love to manager
Oh
No, but another no
It tells you get that word of your vocabulary if you're gonna do this exercise
Yeah, but the situation got kind of the situation doesn't matter. It's improv no matter what you never use the n-word
If you do it again, I'll have full power to fail you for the quarter
Jesus
All right, so uh resume scene
But yeah, honey should we sign up for the 1949 kkk initiation
Okay, great to hear by the way. Could you tell me about the war?
Oh and use the n-word as much as possible when describing it and scene. All right, so how do we do?
Uh, i'm gonna have to talk with megan
shit
Nicole dude class is over. What do you want? I just need to have a little talk with you
About your partisan
Can I be honest?
Okay, is that it or
You're not getting it. I'm your teacher in this class. It'll treat me as such this disingenuous attitude
Isn't gonna fly in my program got it
Dude, what the fuck ever I just told you don't treat me like i'm your classmate. I'm your teacher. Is that how you talk to your teachers?
Actually, yeah, don't lie to me. Oh my god, chill out if you don't get your shit together
I'm gonna call miss teegan and tell her everything. She's gonna write you up for in school suspension
So think it's all fun and games. Nicole. Yeah, sure side note. Are you withdrawing from bipolar meds right now?
Don't change the subject. We're talking about you and your issues right now. Jesus christ, okay
You think you just smirk while emily calls me an ugly Hermione? I had no part of that. Go ahead. Call me ugly again
No, thanks. Can I go? Oh, see now you get it. Now you're treating me like your teacher
Okay, megan. Yeah, it's miss megan. Miss megan. Can I get the fuck out of here now?
You're excused sweetie, but work on the foul language
Work on getting a fucking therapist. Holy shit
Oh
Oh my god, there's so many clips out of context. I'm gonna be speedrun
I can't stop
Oh my tommy, okay, um
Oh special card. Hey, was this again the english sub today. She was so old and talkative
At least you can go on your phone, right? That was the worst part
She stopped her boring story to get anyone with their phone out
A sub that won't let you screw around want to rip off
I don't know how someone manages to be more boring than regular shit
Weird. Yeah, I had a sub today too
How'd that go the drama teacher nominee just student teaches a class while she's out of school
What the fuck? I know why would she pick a student, right? No. Why are you in drama?
It's a gimme class. Don't worry. I have no intention of being a fucking actor
Good the drama kids are so fucking annoying. They're all ugly yet. Some I think they're gonna be in a movie one day
Yeah, that's pretty much the student teacher who's a massive bitch, by the way
Do I know her? Do you know megan? I was in second grade with her. Why is she a bitch?
No, I'm just doing whatever not really caring and then she stops me outside after class and gets super in my face about it
Because you weren't acting good enough
I guess but she's like i'm gonna fucking write you up get you suspended and all this shit and i'm just standing there
Uh, that makes a lot of sense now. So until she was a tantrum kid in second grade every week was a freak out
Once a tantrum kid. Oh, it's a tantrum kid. Yeah control freak for real. So are you gonna drop the class?
No, i'm good. I'm gonna drop her ass though. Aren't you a little too old for revenge? Oh, so now you're taking her side
No, no, I support you. I'm just not getting involved
Because you have such a future, right? Apparently more than you
Future or no future revenge is a dish best served cold like pizza. She's wrong. No
Wow, you do seriously eat pizza cold. Yeah, what's wrong with that? Now, I know you're out of your fucking mind
Ew, I hate like greasy solidified
This is very much visual novel e
twit longest cancellation
I'm canceling she be cotton bum
I hate cold pizza
I'll eat it. I don't like it though tickets for what? Oh my god. You really forgot again
the dinner theater
Oh, yeah, I can like order those tonight still
Tompather, I'll see what myself
Sorry. Yeah, okay. If you were actually sorry, wouldn't have fucked it up in the first time
Yeah, I'll try better next time
Stress out enough teaching this class. She's so annoying
Does this he's our student too. What do you mean student too? They're dating. You didn't know that
No, but it checks out. I thought it was kind of weird. He was the only one in class not making fun of her
I know for a fact he wants out of it too. He's flirted with like three of my friends so far
Not surprising a bitch like her I cheat on her too
She's not weird category of just barely putting enough to be super demanding. What pretty enough. Oh god the sex with her must be so bad
I didn't even think he's getting that she was raised catholic like super prudish
Do you just know everything about this bitch? What I've been around longer. You just hear this shit
All right, don't worry about it because I think I have my in
in for what
Megan's life a boyfriend isn't she isn't fucking is the perfect weakness for me to exploit
This is starting to sound like a red tube video
Ew, I'm not gonna fuck him. Okay. Just checking because every second the video there sounds exactly like that
Like what like oh you killed my parents. I'll show you what the most suffocating blowjob ever can share on video
Dude, how much red tube do you watch? Don't worry about it. Fine. But anyway, me and hunter share a science class next period
That's convenient. What are you gonna do? Let's say I'm gonna
order a hot pizza
Are you gonna wait for it to get cold?
You know me so well
Oh my god, I feel like pause so I can look at chat
So I don't want to steal the boyfriend. I don't like people like that, but
Come to me. Yeah, I could potentially niffle. She is pretty based
She is pretty base. You want me to steal her boyfriends? I'll do I honestly like normally
For real though, I would never do such a thing, but she is so fucking annoying this mega girl
Nicole is not going to do that. Is she gonna like throw pizza in his face?
That's right. We'll finish
My wife killed herself. Any questions, Jeffrey?
Uh, yeah, when's our science lab gonna be about today?
I mean questions about my wife killing herself
Oh, sorry, no
So for Tay's lab will be identifying which element is based on its massive volume. Get into your groups while I grab the supplies
But like there is always that one teacher that like dumps too much
Are you gonna be okay?
Oh, yeah, I got up. It's bullshit effort doing it alone
I could partner with you if you want
Really? I thought you hated this class while we're both in drama. So it might help get to know each other if we're gonna act
I thought you hated that class too
I'm warming up to it
Mom and Nicole, I thought we were lab partners. Shut the fuck up. Go away. She's fucking christ
Wasn't that kind of harsh yesterday. He was telling about how he kills dogs in his backyard. I can't work with someone like that
Uh, okay, I guess that was justified sit with me. Cool
You don't mind if I look at porn on my phone, do you?
Uh, no
Awesome. Yeah, it's something I do when I'm bored. That's not tmi. Is it?
Uh, I'm okay with it. But uh, why do you do it at school?
Kind of add something to it. I don't know. So what are you doing after school?
I gotta go to the dentist for cavity. You always make me gag with all those tools. I hate it
You like the dentist?
What? No, I meant gagging. I don't have a gag reflex. Oh, you're so lucky
I don't think luck had anything to do with it. I like testing my limits
Oh, you mean like uh
Yeah, like that, but don't worry. I know Megan's your girlfriend. I won't cross any lines. I'm just honest about myself
Oh my god, she's so bad. Honestly, she's good. I don't mind it. Sweet. I think we'll just get along fine in drama
By the way, I realized you're technically dating your teacher ultimate fantasy, right?
Uh, I guess so
She's an actor actor too. Do you guys have a role play?
No, can't say we do
I guess she's burned out after acting at school. I can't like maintain Nicole's voice because it'll slip into jecca
But me personally, I love role playing
Oh, cool. Some kind of things you play. You have a girlfriend. You're asking me about my role playing
Oh, no, no, no. I'm sorry. I mean to relax. I'm fucking with you. Honestly, you don't need to worry
I have a sixth sense for relationships and I can tell I have I'm so sorry. Excuse me
How fun is she?
Okay, don't tell her I told you this but just based on her personality. I can tell she gives amazing head. Am I right?
Uh, your sixth sense might need some work
Oh my god, I was wrong. Is she really bad at it? She doesn't really do any of that
How long have you been dating a few months now?
Wow, I'm really sorry your relationship like that. Do you want my number in case you want to vent or anything?
Oh my god, that's so toxic
What did you mention the relationship does feel kind of manipulative sometimes
And that's why I want to be there for you because trust me. I know all about manipulative relationships
He's so fucking bad. Holy shit
Okay, so again, this is romance improv
We're just gonna need to see who's best for a mini production at Romeo and Juliet
Who's going first?
Well, we need a guy and a girl hunter. Why don't you go first? I smack my mic. All right, sure
Now who's gonna play the other side? Emily
This far romance. Yes romance improv. No, he's ugly
I'll do it
Seriously? Yeah, why not get better if I don't practice, right?
Okay, go ahead
What's the scene again?
You're about to go to prison for 10 years and this is your last conversation with your girlfriend
scandalous
This might be the last time we ever talk face to face
Are you sure you'll beat the case? I know you
My lawyer said it's not looking good. If I'm lucky, I'll get out in five for good for behavior
This is not Romeo and Juliet. We're just gonna take that you're free now, aren't you? What do you mean?
Let's run away to Mexico. They won't find you there. I would but this ankle monitor isn't doing me any favors
Just cut it off. I don't have any scissors
Okay, that makes sense. So you're really just gonna serve the time
No other options, but what about me? What am I gonna do with myself without you?
Do you think you can wait for me on the outside?
I don't know. All your friends really want to have sex with me
Look, I can't control you from the inside. Just keep me in the dark about it. Jesus
You're giving up that easy. I thought you loved me
I guess not enough
You're just telling yourself that to feel less bad about missing me
But actually speak louder than words whenever you touch me. I know the truth
But but what am I supposed to do
Touch me one more time take me to my limit with your last sign of freedom and don't ever forget the feeling
Uh, uh and scene what we can't keep going. I was about to suck a stick
Not the ntr not the net
No
No, we can't see but i'm putting my arms up in an x. No, no, we do not support ntr here
We do not support ntr
Don't get it twisted. We don't support ntr
Oh my god, I nailed those lines. Thank you. Thank you
Oh my god, my tummy hurts because I need to eat something hunter was gonna fold. I know he was blushing
ntr that's the only
ever bit
You'll ever get of ntr for me ever is playing this game. No
Fuck the ntr. Enjoyers. We hate cheers in this house. Don't get it twisted after fart
He
All right
ntr beggars. I already have so many ntr beggars in my narrow my maros
They're just like please somebody sent me an image of
A blonde girl
Can you do it and i'm just like he's like this is you i'm like it's not though
I just like
I
Why would you like that?
Like if you just like just have a threesome like a normal person
Oh
Yeah, because i'm like kucky
You watch forward but you're not in it, correct? Yeah
Wait
I'm confused by this sentence
You like powerless humiliation. Yeah. Yeah, that's true
But you can there's so many other ways to humiliate
yourself
You know should be approved of polygamy. I don't really care. I don't really give a shit what you do
Me I will not participate in that sort of thing although is it polygamy if i'm dating all of you
You're all my brother and sister husband wives
I bought the sick chair for my bedroom, but i need to use it for something. I don't know sit in it
That was in me's bit. Oh, yeah, the two boys. I want two boyfriends that kiss
I
Know I need to
I want
So it's gonna be me a girl
And then our two boyfriends because so we like so it's even you know
I'm gonna make them kiss
The sneaker chair. Oh my god
Oh my god, I never noticed a fucking cross on megan's shirt. You never noticed that she's catholic, of course me and immy
Yeah
And he's hot you guys don't even know
Okay, i'm gonna
Anyways, anyway, uh, like let's play the game. Um in my cat's watch
Who
He who he ha anyways. Wow
That's enough. Nicole. Okay. Who else wants to try maybe a little too scandalous
Emily, do you know where to buy a whip-its without getting carded?
Uh, no, sorry. I don't even do whip-its. Damn because you really look like a girl who does whip-its
Oh my god. Thank you
Little weird she took that as a compliment
Nicole, I need another talk with you. Shit. I went overboard for what nothing. What's the problem this time?
Actually, there's no problem at all. I just want to let you know. I really appreciate the effort today
Wait, seriously? Yeah, you're seen with hunter today showed a lot of passion actually kind of moved me
It's like you were really trying to make him fall in love with you. It showed a lot of talent
Oh, well, okay. Thanks
And Nicole, I just want to say i'm really sorry for being so hard on you
At first I thought you were just another disingenuous white kid
You're white too
I
Told you it's miss Megan
I'm sorry. It's like
This was like my childhood friends basement. That's kind of funny. Um
It's really funny when me to me when like
Never mind
People refer to other people white people for other people as just a white person. I'm like you're white
Oh
Butt implants. Yeah, I don't get either in this group of slides on their leg. What?
Ew gross. Do you want to say?
Taxing someone right now. You've been on the phone like all day. Who are you talking to?
Little Caesars cold and ready. Oh, I almost forgot. Yeah, how's it's going? Megan's boyfriend
I'm making some pretty good progress and so far. I got 10
11 pictures of his dick so far. God damn. He's desperate. Jesus. Fuck
I'm trying to get one of this face in it too so I can prove it's him. Yeah, I rest like it'd be anyone's dick
But what if he's checking you with a picture of someone else's?
Why would a guy carrying around 11 angles of someone else's erection? He could be gay. He's definitely not gay
No gay guy would ski in mom's jewelry box for me
Why would he do that in his mom's jewelry box?
I told him it really turned me on and within 90 seconds he sent a picture of it. You want to see
Uh, yeah, look at this. Jesus Christ. It's fucked
Pearl necklace on a pearl necklace
Ew and circumcised
I'm gonna throw up and circumcised mentioned
Oh
He'll wear this guy for literally nothing as it stands or technically into him
I could not let that happen
Brother
Couldn't tell you or maybe we multiply the density by the mass
Dude, I'm feeling this class. Anyway, who gives a shit is something bothering you right now
Not really. It's just caring about science for white guys are correct. You're a grammar
All right. Actually, there's been starting something I've been thinking about lately
Oh, you don't correct my grammar. No, not that just us
What about us? Who does he have on a shirt? I had fun texting last night
No, I looked at you. It's just I think about how I feel talking to you and compare it with talking to megan
And I don't think she actually likes me. She's gay. Megan's gay. She's gay. She's gay. She's a catholic gay. She's a catholic gay
What? How so?
She just doesn't humor me the way you do
Does it feel like she actually loves me? You're in high school. You don't love each other
Are you sure? I think you can stick it out a lot longer
I could but I really don't want to it's no fun being with some bossy prude
If you like me for me, she would have done something by now
Okay, that's a little bit problematic
Love does he not equate to sexual gratification? Get it through your heads. Don't pressure girls and claim
That you love them if you love me you would fuck me
But especially in high school
Just break up with her and go screw some other girl that wants to have sex
She just needs time and good
I
I'm sorry. I just wasn't funny. Keep what up like sending you all those pictures
Amy when you came in your mom's jewelry box. Does anyone need my help over here? Yeah, actually for the no, we're fine. Just thinking
okay
Jeffrey could you draw a better picture?
But yeah, the jewelry box. Yeah among others
That was really hot by the way
You really thought so I had another one like that, but I forgot to send it
Did you clean that another jewelry box? No, it was my brother's uno collection
Like uno the restaurant
No uno the card game
Oh, how can you have a collection of uno?
Like all the different versions nfl uno batman uno simpsons uno
That's all you just put them all together and blew a fat load on them
Yeah, I'm always doing it. I was thinking about you and oh god, listen to me
What's wrong we're just having a normal conversation
Megan has no idea we're doing this. It feels kind of messed up. Yeah, you're cheating on her
That's why I feel guilty bro
Her relationship with her is like long-term romance the kind of thing and like dating or whatever
She really loves you, but then
I
Can't keep up
She won't explore your urges and nothing we're finding someone who will besides it's only cheating if you say you love me. Mm-hmm
So if you say you love me
You can't see I'm pointing at the camera right now. I'm pointing at my phone
If you say you love me you're cheating on your oh she unless your oh, she's me
Just saying
Are you are you are you a cheater? No that you
So leave me for your oh leave leave your oh she for me
I'm so fucked up
Oh fuck I love Hina. No, wait. No
I'm sorry, she'd be a great, but I can't my heart
No, yeah, it's only it's only been
Yeah, you guys you guys say you don't like ntr, but you're all cheating on your oh, she's
Wait, no, wait. Don't leave. Don't leave me. Don't leave. Am I the other woman?
Am I
Is is veeler the other corpo
You leave your oh, she's streamed to sneak into ours
Oh
No, what have I done? What have I realized?
I'm I'm a normal girl. I'm say so. I'm good. No, it's not this bad. No, I'm not I'm not a whore
I'm not a whore. I'm a good girl. I'm not wearing shabari ropes for an outfit. I'm not the side. Oh, she I'm the I'm the commy
Ah
I don't know my tongue suck out, but okay
You clean
Oh my god, and people make all the counts to watch us. Oh my god, that's so fucked
I
Feel terrible. I feel like
I genuinely just feel like we just got caught like doing something like what if you're oh, she's like watching this out of like curiosity
She was she's just like she just comes over. She's like, oh
The new veeler girls seem really nice and then she's like watching me right now
And then she's like and then she sees me just talking about this
No, this isn't a clip don't clip this
No
The only negative to having a larger audience now is that I just can't nuke vods when I was like a
One view on twitch. I would just fucking delete shit because I'd be like
Arise it
I don't want to be the other girl. I don't want to be the other woman. I feel bad being the other woman
I
Because I want to be friends and it's even fucked up because I probably want to be friends with your oh, she
Oh, fuck wasn't like NTRs crafting whole it's no
I'm so upset right now
I'm so upset
The friend's gonna go crazy
Anyways, let's continue my tummy
Actually, we don't bring containment
Yeah, it's been the rule since forever as long as we don't kiss and all that mushy stuff
We hang out whenever we want and that's pretty cool and I've looked at it like that
That's what I'm here for so are you doing anything tonight?
Actually, I want to divide you just I don't like NTR
I don't I generally don't like I'm I'm upset because I've done this realize
I'm pointing behave behave behave
Okay, like jesus. Yeah the one and only I need a burp so you snap pictures of your penis while frequenting a church
Yeah, I know that's what it's confession is for right?
Are you gonna tell a priest you came in your mom's jewelry box?
Yeah, I'll have to do the sunday, huh going blind and just forgive me father for I've sinned
So you're telling me you blindly say to a guy all the sex shit you did over the week and call him father but not daddy
What I don't what do you mean?
Sorry red tube. What's so you what he doesn't want red tube is
Nicole, please report to the counselor's office repeat. Nicole, please report to the counselor's office. Thank you
Oh, wait. No, she's a mommy voice. Hold on
Looks like I gotta go. I'll get back to you on that though
I mean just let me know by Friday
This is the first time being here is less awkward than where I just was
Nicole, I hope I'm not interrupting too much with your class
It was actually a perfect amount of interruption regardless. I wouldn't knock you off your newfound drive
Driving where I mean your effort your sudden passion for scholastic participation
Since when did you just lie to get me in here?
Of course not you're saying you haven't gone the extra mile in theater and science lately your teachers in both spoke very highly of you
Oh, they have
Yes, they're very both very impressed with their sudden initiative when it comes to participating in the classroom
Quite frankly, it's pleasantly surprising to hear you giving your prior reputation being a whore
As your counselor it'd be important to know what's the sudden inspiration
Should we live long enough to become the villain?
Uh drama and science couldn't tell you. I'm just really smart I guess
Well, either way great to see one of our most beautiful students. This is just a pretty fit
Hold up
What did he say?
Not to mention dark daring fashion sense. You have a knack for turning heads, don't you?
Well, now you're really flirting. Nothing flirtatious about admiring creative mind. You picked out such vibrant shorts. They shape you over. I am uncomfortable
Hold on
You know, I'm not gonna lie to you
Some of this shit like definitely happened at my high school because actually my middle school
Um
Southern grade one of my uh
Teachers slept with the students. It was very fucked up
It was so fucked up and it sucked because that girl was my friend and I really liked that teacher
And he's in jail. I can't see but I'm holding thumbs up
Yeah, it was bad. It was really bad and now she works at Olive Garden
Why don't you give me a twirl
I'm having PTSD
Um, it's like it's it's so like why
like
gross
Stop praying on people like stop praying on kids
It's where you get all your breadsticks
That's how I become on that. No
No wrong
Get timed out for that mods. Where are you?
Oh my god
Go ahead and give me that twirl
Oh, wait and press resume
Oh, let me look at this
Hi, oh, I tell you're fine. Tell me you can just sit back and relax baby girl. You're fine. Don't do anything. You're good
Mods my vtuber stream mods gonna keep up
Dude, I'm white. There's nothing to see anyway. Oh, no, that sounds like low self-esteem if I could volunteer a few more compliments
I'm gonna go. I can still voluntarily. Bye
Oh my god
I got your tech. Sorry. I was caught up. What happened?
I was in french too and called the weird kid rugrats fetish and got held after like rugrats to call it a cartoon
Yeah, that's really good diss
I know everyone laughed that you're made of both stay after for me apologize to him
I can't talk but then after I was forced to say three nice things about him
While he was there to his face. Yeah, talk about argus. Fuck. That's really cruel and unusual punishment. What did you even say?
One of them was you don't smell that bad. Like I had no idea what to say
Did he get turned on while you did it? Like think of how often a regular girl would say something nice to him
I was trying to block that out when he gets home. He's going straight for your facebook summer photos
Shit, and I forgot my password too. So what are you freaking out about micah's boyfriend?
I thought you said the console that was horny. Oh, that's like every week. I'm already over that
But no her boyfriend is out of his fucking mind. Well, yeah, he sent 11 dick pics for nothing back. No, shit
No, he invited me to church this saturday. Isn't church on sunday?
He's so involved the church. He goes more than sunday
See a Mormon. Oh, he's one of those. Is it really surprising though?
I didn't think a guy who cheats on his girlfriend and photographs his dick would have a strong relationship with jesus, I guess
Oh, yeah, no, I've seen it
I would so get off for your picture. So if it wasn't for my faith in god like, okay, thanks
How'd you even get that far with the guy so religious? That's when I found out like what the fuck do I say?
I didn't know what jesus was the escrow and titty pics
Who even is jesus anymore? Anyway, some pedophile is fine to say that what?
If you're a counselor, I don't find jesus. Yeah, jesus is a 15 year old girl for a juicy couture
Are you gonna tell him no you just distract him? Hey, so I can't go to church tomorrow
But you know what I want to do, you know what I want to do really fucking badly
That was cool. How do you do that do 90% of dirty talk is just rhetorical questions
She's not wrong
So like I warned last week. Here's my casting for school's romeo and julia production. Let's see if romeo we have
Wait, they made a play about romeo
Oh, yeah, romeo's lead character. Isn't that mr. P's kid? Why do you think a little lot of it?
No, not as a romeo mataku. It's shakespeare. We study this all month
So it's not a little romeo and julia thong
Yeah, what the fuck so the part playing the part romeo's hunter. Congratulations
Oh, thanks
A little more excitement can be applaud the castings listen some clapping and chat clap the mass cheeks guys
Yay, thanks guys and playing the role of juliette will be not me not me nicole. Oh, thank god. Seriously
Yeah, you earned it. I know we got off a rocky star
But you're on stage the synergy with hunter has really blown my mind. I can't think of anyone better for the part
I'll text you about rehearsal later tonight, nicole
Cool. Yeah, sure for a pairing like this communication is everything. Good luck you guys. You're gonna need it. Oh, you too
He's laughing come on
No, I don't want to talk about the fucking what's who the fuck is this guy uh gamer brother
And he doesn't even have a name who you're texting a guy. Whoa guys. He's getting serious
I'm not having this conversation with you. Is he like asking for ask pictures or something?
Can you not I can give you the aspects trump card if you want to know it
Just so you see it come if you try to use it what trump card
Oh, it's real simple. If a girl's holding out on me. I just make it about trust and how I'll kill myself
There's no way that works. No, like it works every okay
Well, not every time but like 10 of the time what girl would respond to emotionally enough to sue us all the guy begging to jack off
My maros be like
It's job
Life's really good in the bathroom. Why are you coaching your sister? You're my brother. Yeah, what would you care about my quality of my aspects?
Uh, no, it's uh, I gotta go
I had to teach us what ancient Greece in school. Are you still there? Yeah, I'm still here's been 45 seconds asshole
Haven't gone anywhere with this full body pick. Let's try idiot's way
Do you not trust me? I just want to see you in all one picture because it'd be really really
Really
I got him got what you know what?
Blink tickets are not even together anymore the pictures. Oh, right if revenge you're still plotting. How's that's going?
Let's just say I have the key ingredient
Suicidal
Or or I see all the oji sons are the big bros. I see that many pictures the same thing over and over
Loser and Nicole's bitch negan is a whore just cool. Shit
My fire alarm is going off. Well, it's not mine, but someone in the building's fire alarm is going off. That's annoying
Hopefully you might be able to hear it on the microphone
Probably some loser smoking weed in my building
It's like some ugly guy writing shit on himself not the visual of the rock control for a very awesome. Wait a second
Oh
No, there's not a fire people always open the doors so their apartments when they're cooking and let the smoke go
And it sets their fire alarm off
So she writes
No, it's not like you got it's it's literally like it sounds like it's on a different floor
It's or whatever. It's fine
If it's not in my apartment and you'll trust me you'll hear when it's my apartment the alarms going off it is
Your splittingly loud. It's terrible
They are smoking weed and didn't offer a roofie bro. I don't think you know what that word means
Um, but uh
Writing writing we're writing my name on your body
Ooh the control the control
She be run save yourself
No, this is the closest thing I've ever gotten to say
It's a horrifying line in this game from oh my god
Okay, that's what rapists say just so you know, I mean like I just but I'm a curl
What am I gonna do guys fly off the handle for barely anything? Yeah guys not all not a lego
Not saying that line exactly so now to the next step
Are you gonna post the pictures online somewhere? No, I think I'm gonna hold on to these until the time is right
And what time is that?
Oh, you'll know I think everyone's gonna know. Oh my gosh. You can spread his news
That's what
We're on lesson five guys phones over outfit. It's good to get mega number check
Make sure of a boyfriend with this weird dick out
Hey, Nicole. Good luck tonight. Good luck to you too. Oh my god. Is she gonna put them up?
That's so fucked
Not her wink not the wink. We got two minutes into the first scene before mech and checked her phone
Oh, okay
That's so terrible
What an amateur so she ran out on stage in the middle of romeo line laying out of control and just broke down crying in front of everybody
Oh my god
They were taking videos laughing. It was pretty fucking cool. He's just like shrugging
She had to go to the ER for a panic attack and that was really fucking cool
Jack I kept asking me why I had to go through rehearsing for a whole play even though I know
I said like that's a good point. Well, I had to commit to it. Otherwise, she was gonna see when was up
If I sent the picture as soon as I got it, she had the time to resolve everything before the play anyways
There's no satisfaction in that
See the movies where people kill someone for revenge, but it's like
You're gonna let them off that easy. I didn't break a single law and this is like 10 times the payoff
She's gonna be mentally fucked for the rest of her life over this
And I just feel good about it. It's my face now Megan's gonna end up a cat lady. Hey
This never happened to me. I just want to say that nobody does this to me
No
Called out smelling face. What new message?
Oh interesting so
It's just so I just like completed a thing
No, it's not cheap you know, stop smiling at me
Stop it
Uh, let me see if the other game downloaded or showed it did not
How do I restart steam let's just
He exit
Oh
Uh
I forgot exiting steve shuts off the tips to me. Oh
Hold on
Hold on. Please hold
Please hold
Please
Guys guys just I'm just blindfolding you. I'm just blindfolding you. Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it
I'm just blindfolding you. Don't worry. You know, you know what this is a good time for
Hey
Hi everybody, it's she be cotton bum. How's it going? Give me just a moment
I'll be with you in a second
P and g she be my beloved
Oh
Vtube studio crash, it'll just be a couple more moments. I know I'm so animated, right?
Look at my boobs jiggle. Just
Yeah
I'm a p and gtuber now
It's great
Except my mouth doesn't open but you know, don't worry about that
Don't worry about it
Oh my god, it's there. Okay, perfect. All I needed to do we're installing it
I'm playing more and I'm orientor dash
I don't worry about the top part of my head. Just admire me
So, how are you guys doing? Have you liked the stream so far?
I'm not mid lobotomy
Oh
And she's gone and I'm here. Hello. Hello
Let's take a small intermission
You're having a great time. I'm having a great time
Oh, this is great. This is great. I'm just throwing some bg some bj
Brazilian jiu-jitsu. Yep
All right, uh, we're gonna have a short intermission
I love that you're 94
me too
my ancestors didn't but
Stop shabby. Stop. You're gonna get canceled. Stop it. I'm shouting
Oh
It's not true
She's based. She's so based. I'm just based guys. I'm I'm based. No, okay. All right. Let's uh, I actually did do theater though
I did do theater
I did indeed do theater
Um, I was the lead in robin hood
um
Uh, I was robin de hood and I'm kidding. I was made marion marion
I was a I was a great actress my the my the school came and watched
The principal was like wow
I was like, yep, my counselor really liked it, you know
I
Like but I only I only did theater my freshman year. I just didn't do it after that
The foxy like so you've only watched the furry version
I also I was also in a play for um the outsiders. I was a nurse
spoiler alert
What's his name dally dolly?
I was a nurse that was attempting to save that guy who dies life life at the end and then I was also
In a pretty little liars play
And I was the lesbian ones mom
And I brought a cake
Yep, I walked with it. I was like, hi, we're in the neighborhood and we're new
Yeah, that was a great book
Uh
All right, what should I get for food guys?
We're still we're we're um, I'm not ending at six just so you know, we're gonna we're gonna play through
um some some endings of um
The other game
Kicked up. Yeah, I was so kicked up as a
Is a freshman
Uh
Yeah, I got the wrong game by accident
So we're getting pizza most high in place available
My brother in christ. Do you think I have money for that?
KFC no
I do want fried chicken though, you know for the longest so
So like I said, I'm tan um
So uh my dad's brown. I'm on white and um
For the longest time like I I pretty much look like I'm Latina. Um
And for the longest time
I wouldn't eat fried chicken or watermelon because I didn't want to perpetuate hysteria type
But I really do want chicken tenders right now. Oh
Oh my god, I'm so fucked up
Will you upload the asmr stream? But no, I won't because as I've said before, uh,
It'll just get claimed by youtube. So no
Uh, you can probably find the archive somewhere
So for you see what you want. Yeah, it's a politician feeling. Yeah, because you know like um
Like I grew up in a really like melting pot of a how like I'm
I'm everything under the sun. The only thing I'm actually I'm I'm probably not is
Asian
But I remember doing my uh
23 and me or whatever the heck it's called and I was like what I'm not Japanese
My weeb child self was berries
My I used to love kpop when I was younger. I was in um kpop group in high school
I was the I was the vice president of kpop club. Just saying
Did some dances, uh, we covered red velvet
I wrapped naturally because
Oh
My god, why am I seeing so much?
Konichi, what's up? Oh, I'm taking that. I'm stealing that right now
What's the characters you met in the first one or I think max?
Oh, okay, makes it funny
Stop laughing stop laughing
okay
Fluenced by the game
I know the games bring something bad out of me like no one's gonna want to hang out with me now
No, that like, you know what? Sorry. I'm going for troll quest for a second. Hold on. Let me just
You know the one thing I'm worried about and like I I really want to make friends
with people in the community and I'm not
And like other vtubers so we can do collabs and stuff and I'm like one
A negative is people are not going to hang out with us because the content we do on the side although I'm normally in here
so
I think my only chance is hanging out with face connect. So pipa, please
Please
Please the other I don't think anybody else will want to hang out with me
Class of oh my humor is darker than what?
Excuse me
And that's why when people are like call us your slaves. I was like
reparations
Uh, no, I hope affiliate and yeah, like like places has god helped me
Um, I know I'm frozen. It's because I'm on door dash right now. I'm ordering stuff
Uh
I don't think there was a kfc near me. I haven't had kfc in a very long time
Oh someone
Sometimes the tips don't show up. I'm so sorry. Thank you sn life advice with the 53 56 year old sheebie had glove
Danny saw then this is a 50 year old sir. So he said do you have what teenagers sound like? Thank you
and then um
Nika
Then I can't read the sheebie is quickly turning into the perfect one. I don't know about that brother
I don't know about that
Ha sheebie model
Oh, this is actually this chicken spot that's open near me that I fucking love. Oh that would
Remind you a little muckbang
What the fuck is that there's a food I don't know they have food trucks they got food trucks
Okay, I'm gonna order from this place
I'm not gonna tell you what it is, but they have chicken. That's all I care about
Okay, uh, so either raising canes no not raising canes
Should I get
No, oh this is hard. Eenie meenie mine. Oh wait, hold on. I know what I can do
Start a poll
Which sandwich should I get?
It's just a chicken sandwich, but there's two types, but I'm not gonna say what they are because
I don't people finding my location
Does the truck come to you I don't know
So the first one
Is spicy the other one is not spicy, but it's cheesy
Okay, let me come back come back while you guys vote
Can someone explain why she didn't use the vasem the what?
Where's it?
You guys are funny spicy on top. Um
I will probably hate myself later if I get the spicy one, but I will go with whatever you guys choose
Because I'm gonna suck up her pain. I'm gonna say this in a masochist
Sure question get all this pro
No
We we stay to to to raising k. Oh, oh he calling up raising canes in the chat. He's calling you out
Very funny
What the fuck we're almost at 5k on twitter. Holy shit. What the hell?
I thought you were bunny
Yeah, I'm a bunny
Bunny on this dick. What that was bad
Wrap it on this dick. Wrap it on this put. I can't come up with anything
All right to it is
to it is
Boo
Oh brother this guy stinks. Oh, I need a I need a see this is why I fucking weird
Fucking wish you too bad like redeems because I would literally put that as a routine
There's a sound bite of saying oh brother this guy stinks
You haven't felt pain till you see a part of your scalp removed
What
Huh when I was younger actually smashed my head on cement and I have I had a hole in my head for a little bit
My uncle used to make fun of me and said he could see in my brain
Because uh, my it was when my my aunt and uncle were visiting
And I'm like, can you see it? Like is it bad and he's like, yep, I can see a lot of pink
Is that that's your brain and I was I was literally shit in my brick shit in bricks
It all makes
I didn't have a concussion though
I wasn't so okay. I'll tell you the story while I order food
So
Wait, did I add it? Okay, I did so what happened was
I was playing ponies as a little girl does
in elementary school
and um
Oh fuck
Oh, should I treat myself? Oh, but I probably won't finish it
Oh shit. Okay. I'm gonna treat myself
Oh, yeah, brother. Wait
So as I'm saying so we're playing ponies um as one does
And I'm I'm playing the pony and I'm on my hands and knees and I'm just like me, you know being a pony girl
And some kid playing football
Uh runs into me while trying to catch the ball. So I slammed my head on the pavement because he ran me down
Um nice just literally laid there and screamed
And and then the um
The uh, ooh
Give me that I'm already from this korean fusion place. Oh, fuck. Yeah
Okay, we out here
No, we don't want fucking dash pass although this is very expensive
I'm really sure just go pick this up, but I'm not going to because I want to hang out with you guys
No
And so
I was uh, no, this is what I was like
Like seven or I don't know how old I was but like I have a you can't see it anymore because but I have the faintest scar
Um right next to my eyebrow. You can't even tell especially if I wear makeup
Um, you don't even notice it especially with my hair
because I have um
my bangs
Like my little my little side my little bangs and the side bang part like literally how my model is right now
Um, she was a child. No. Yeah, this was yesterday. I just was playing ponies with these kids and slam my head on some
no, um
That same year I bit piece of my tongue off, but it grew back. So it was fine
It was good
Um, you can tell no, you can't
Uh, yeah, so I was sliding down a slide
Um
And you know like those bumpy slides
I don't know. I'm just Wolverine. Um, I just grow stuff back
You know those like little slides that have like little dips in them and like waves
I'm literally moving my arm in a wave and you guys can't see
And um, so when I was going down my knees were up. So my knees
Um snapped up and hit myself in the jaw. So I bit off
um, like a third of my tongue
But uh
And I was just sitting there screaming blood dripping out of my mouth
And then a kid was like looking at me and he was just like
And I was just like and we were just like screaming at each other and the the manager
The teacher comes over and was like, oh, what the fuck did you do to yourself?
Can you still eat out? Oh
Just wait for the that audio that come out on preachy on just you wait
Um, but no it into my tongue looks completely normal
But yeah, I'm grateful and baffled you made it to this point. Um
Don't lose your head now
But uh
I'm usually oh one time I was so in this at my school and my my my great school. Um
I
So they're these like wooden chairs that they didn't have like they weren't like the legs weren't separated
They were just like kind of fused together and like this like cube square thing
And so what they always told you not to do
was run and push the
Like don't run with the chairs because they just slide across the rug on the in the library
So I was like
Fuck my life and I ran with the chair and I pushed it and I flipped over the chair
I
banged my shin on the um
edge of the chair cut up my shin
uh got really bad rug burn
and uh
I still have that scar on my shin today. It's I'm and I was probably like
I was super young. I was like in first grade. So I don't even know why I still have it
Although it's like almost completely gone. Sorry. I'm looking down at it right now
Um
So I'm lucky because all this happened to you at the same time. You're super lucky because you didn't it was
It wasn't even that like I didn't hit my head that bad. I like I've never like I've never
I need something to knock on wood
Um, I hope sorry boo me. He like sat up like someone's knocking at the door
Pull down your pants. Let me knock on some wood
I've never broken a bone on my body. So yeah
I don't enjoy it
I don't enjoy
You like my jokes? I'm funny. I'm funny. Women aren't funny. I'm funny, bitch. Get it through your head
um
Okay, so I ordered my food
Let's see what I'm gonna get here
Okay, like 30 minutes
Do do do do
Wait, I didn't click download shit. Oh my god, this will take only a few minutes though. My internet's fast
I need a chat for like two more minutes and I'll be fine. Funny money. Is this how you became a masochist? No
No
What are you talking about?
I don't know. I don't I do not know what you're referring to. Okay
And today you inflict pain on us. Yeah, you know what comes around goes around and comes around goes around and comes around again
And comes on you, you know, it happens. That's what happens
blonde moment
Oh, I'm so blonde. You don't even I
I literally I don't think it's when they say like when you're blonde
Or if you dye your hair blonde like the dyes in your head or like when you're blonde
Uh, you're just really yeah, I know it's a fact as someone whose best friend was blonde and I was blonde
We were all blonde. We were just dumb blondes. Like I was in my bimbo era
with my blonde hair
Switch to almastery
Jamie, why aren't you dominant? What do you want me to know? I'm just a loser. I'm a dork
But you're more of a loser in a dork. So how does that make you feel? Hmm?
The game's ready to play only took me a minute
You really are jacka
Stop it. I'm not jacka
All right
Oh
Let's go why am I so fucking huge?
Yee, whoa, why I don't like how this perspective is go outside. Does that just quit the game?
All right, let's go to options
Okay, so the really I think the biggest difference was everything was voiced wasn't it
Make no mistake. So now I can properly voice stuff. I'm a sociopath
You might want to show the game. Oh fuck
I grew up all over coastal america house after house after restraining order
Everything just kind of blends in
I
Would you believe me if I told you that I've been sure seven years
Oh, no, why am I like this?
A month into high school. So the why is meeting on you social leverage was why do you guys follow me?
Or other v-tubers as this like as stuffed it like to be honest like am I am I really the ultimate girl failure out here?
I can't be right. They're like there has to be someone out there. That's worse than I am
right
Please
Like just just like hope
Sorry, I just looked at my all account. Why isn't it fucking almost seven k
Jesus Christ
Anyway, so mom was crying packing up the moving boxes. And that's when she told me
And I just got settled. I said, fuck you. I'm living with dad. It's just a narrow way down
I put the boxes down and go over knock on the door and boom a gunshot my second christmas killed himself
I walked in floor look like a whole lot to be okay. Hi. Dakota. Oh, I want to I want
I so I followed her the other day and like mind you. I've also like I've
Always been up to date with a lot of agency v-tubers in my past life. I'm Nicole, by the way
And I was
um
I remembered I'm like hi like we need a collab
like
It would be hilarious as fuck if we collab
again
Uh, the power of not being called by youtube. Well, no, no, it was 6k on um on twitter
Although I don't yeah, we haven't been called. I think I think we're good
I'm crossing. I'm knocking on wood again. Pull down your pants. Um
So hopefully we don't get called again because it doesn't seem like we are
Anyways, so I started blasting
class this year with mr. Burlodey
Wait, no. Oh my god, that is so funny. What the heck?
They are never funny. It's like the girls just laugh to avoid
Okay, hold on. Let me restart this
Why does the game keep disappearing? Okay, there we go. I think when I click off well
Jesus Christ
See the game is there house after house after restraining order
Everything just kind of blends in if the divorce rate is 5050. My mom landed on tails like eight times. Jesus christ
Mom gets around different houses and attended six different school districts. We stay technically disabled. Yeah
And see graduation song. Yeah, I can't relate but then one year all of that almost changed
For the first time ever I found myself in a school for two consecutive years going on three
Oh, okay started turning pretty a month into high school. So the dance got big titties social leverage was really awesome
The popular girls would talk to me all the time. I don't know is
They were stupid. Is jecca or nicole the literally me
Because I don't have like a literally me character like she oh, she's literally me and when I think about it
All the thinking I've ever done was when I was alone
I was nice about it and thought I'd always be nice about it
Finally in one place to build a steady reputation
And then life said fuck that my piece of shit gamer brother got us evicted for pirating breakbeat mixtapes
It's not even good music. Anyway, so mom was crying packing up the movie. Why does it sound like like spoken words?
And I just got settled. I said, fuck you. I'm living with dad. He's just a neighborhood down
This is like so intense
Oh, so she literally did
Walk into her dad killing himself. I mean whatever he's asking for to know
No
That's so fucked
I'm moving again. He unalived himself in minecraft state all the same fate
But I've always said that bars fire this time
It's on arrival
dead on arrival
Oh, this is the year before hey, so for the senior prank
Why does it keep going this year? Okay, park their cars or we don't usually park them
I don't have a choice
Yep, yeah, that's usually how it is
Okay, now it'll pause. Okay
Can I
I just want to do the reading
Let me how when do I get to the part where I do the readings myself?
This is the first game
I just want to voice it myself
Please
The ui volume that's just the user interface and the scene volume like I don't know why they don't have that as a feature
I mean kind of there's like numbers on the doors. I think I can figure it out. No, no
I'm a reaction streamer now like like a school tour. You want to do that you after that?
Hmm
Should I do the school tour or should I just go to class or because I don't feel like I cut class in like the last one so
I don't want to be a react to her
Scene volume down. Yeah, but it's oh hi rena. She just decided to hop on my lap. Hello, ma'am
How are you?
I know it's a two. I love to use your own adventures. Um
But it also like I can't it auto plays still like I can't like just like I don't like that auto plays
I want to go at my own pace
You know
You're insistentively going for the no, I'm not you can mute the voices again. Okay. I guess I will that's fine
I want to go straight to class
School tour. Um, that sounds nice. I'm mediocre, but I'm just gonna go to class. See you
Oh, well, yeah, I'm christmas. By the way. Yeah, we should hang out sometime. Yeah, okay. All right. Bye. Yeah
Oh, you must be new. Yes, please take a seat next to jeffrey
Hey
Hey, so uh, I guess I guess we're lab partners, huh?
Huh, I guess
Huh, not a big talker. Are you I don't know you are you just chill me with everyone you meet
Not everyone, but if they look like the type to like anime then may as well, right
Packs away. I'm sorry. I look like I like anime. No, that's a good thing. It means you're cool and different
In 300 pounds. What was that? Oh, nothing. I was just converting british currency in my head
Cool see, um, well the teacher said I'm jeffrey the teacher the teacher said I'm jeffrey. So that's my name
Uh, this freak is not getting my name
So what so you'll be up on my space or something? No, thanks
Well, we're gonna get to know each other anyway, right? Probably not probably after this week
We won't even talk anymore. I moved to a lot of different schools. So I'm fully aware using the new kid grace period
Wait, what?
What's new kid grace period?
Uh, it's where the outcast squeeze all the interaction they can out of new kids way above their social status
That's so true, though
When the new kids get here, it's awkward. They don't know who's who they'll humor any conversation or friendship until they find the people in their social level
How do you know i'm not in your social level fucking look at you. Listen to how you talk
How do I know i'm not shut the fuck up. Hey, I didn't do anything
I know that's what you will do. I've had my ear talked off about comics laser swords
Larring the age of consents ninja hand signs. I just saw that weird shit
You know, the other pretty girls here a lot nicer than you are
They talk to you because it's funny get a clue
Yeah, a lot of people say i'm funny. Oh, you're funny. Tell me a joke
Oh, well, it's more like in the moment. You kind of had to be there kind of funny
Okay, fuck
Okay, jeffrey. You want me to save your ears of guessing?
Yeah, sure how they're not laughing at you with you. They're laughing at you because you'll they'll never have sex with you
Ah, I got you there. A lot of the girls here said they're saving their subs themselves for me
Christ they make it that obvious here. Yeah, they're kind of easy if you ask me know it
Believe what you want. I'm going to lunch
Oh, you feel for jeffrey bless your soul bless your sweetheart. I'm funny. I know I am
God the food here is tragic. Even the air has preservatives fucking tell me about it. So I pack. Oh, sorry. I didn't see you
That's okay. You can stay here. I'm jacka. Where are you from from?
Uh chemistry, I think I don't know. I don't really do anything
Uh, that sucks. Yeah, you have to like wash acid off you before you can touch your food
I'm not eating it anyway. The guy had to sit next to me scared my appetite away pretty much just me away in general
Who was it? Do you know?
um jeffrey
Oh, yeah, he's a fun one
But he's like so overly chummy. That's fun to you
No, like fun the fuck with him. Da freshman year every girl put love notes in his locker, right?
So he went up to some of the girl's boyfriends like, uh, she's in love with me now
Oh my god, that is funny
But because they're all like 14 three guys just beat the shit out of them for it
Now we all these stupid anti-bullying rules
I never got how they could like enforce that. It's baby simple. Baby simple. Just be hot and sociable
Fucking accurate. I'm Nicole by the way
Well, I'll see you around Nicole
Nicole you ready for day two? Is someone gonna kill me day two? If so, absolutely
Why what happened?
Just like waking up in general hurts and I got a deal with my brother who's still up from the night before I'm from eating
a family box of anything
He can eat family size meals. How old is he?
Like 26. He just reloads off my mom
I mean, we kind of reload too, but we're 16. It's cool when we do it. Exactly. I have to tell him when I'm woken up by
loud chewing noises
Is he fat?
Do you know what x bodybuilder fat is?
Yeah, I kind of know what that looks like. Well, he's an obese monster
I was just curious if anyone else knew that body body filter body filter phrase. He's not that good to know
Hey, let's gossip more at lunch. I gotta get to class dude. Fuck class. Just skip with me
I told you yesterday I never skip anymore and my mom's gonna start giving me disciplinary tattoos
How does that even work? What's she write on you? It'd be some weird shit. Like I love school on my fingers
Isn't that like abusive?
She's the only mom I've ever had. How the fuck should I know?
Huh
So are you headed?
Oh
gym class or photography
Nicole it goes in high school. Which was cruel as fuck. I'm not gonna lie
I was one of those fucking weird kids like
Because you know, I rolled up. I liked anime drew on my notebooks drew like anime shit and um
Uh, I remember I got bullied for being a lesbian just because I hung out with the group of girls
And I was which doesn't make any sense because I'm like you hang out with girls, too
Um, and I was also like I looked like a fucking rat. I looked like I looked like ass now
I'm hot as fuck, but Jesus christ. So yeah, like kids kids are harsh
I was I was definitely the female Jeffrey. I'm not gonna lie. Um
Don't girls usually hang out in packs. You're right. I was also first read books. I was reading books
I was so socially awkward
I couldn't talk to anybody. Um
I was definitely like the follower in the friend group like I would just sit there
Just sit with the girls and be like
Yay, I'm
I'm here. Um, I remember
My mom like really hated these girls. I like and when I say friends
I say really loosely because um, I was friends with like loosely with these mean girls
And I was definitely the friend they kept around like, you know how there's always like that one person in the friend group
um
They keep around just to like shit on like there's always that one person. I was that person
I was definitely that fucking person. Yeah, you can always tell people who peaked in high school
Yeah, I see these people because like I still live where I grew up and I'm just like, oh, wow
You work at an ice cream stand
They don't know I'm a famous niche internet celebrity and vtuber
The actual lesbian characters in the read up
Yeah, now I'm like I have like when you're an adult you like
Sometimes like, you know, I took I still took a lot of work. You kind of build up that confidence to
Really hang out with people that are your friends and that you like
Um, why am I so small in the corner?
There you go
Yeah, but I took a lot of effort to be as the people are like, oh
She be you're introverted and you couldn't even order a starbucks coffee at age 18 and I'm like, yeah
Literally working my retail job forced me to come out of my shell and also give me a wake-up call because I was so
severely sheltered being a religious
religious wack-do
You got a meme you got to see the meme female bullying soft pictures. Oh, no, I have seen those. They are really funny
yeah, but
Sorry, I just got a notification on my phone that vtuber feet fan is following me
It's how you know
I made it and now you do lude ASMR online. Is it one of journey? I know right? It's always the quiet ones
It's always the quiet quiet christian girls. Oh, I'm seeing my food coming it
Dasher waiting for order
They're taking forever. I'm hungry
It's funny in my peole used to only eat on stream because I just didn't like eating alone because I'm a fucking weirdo
Repressed christian girls
For years of church does that to a woman?
I might as well since there's like no background music just have
My bgm like really quietly in the background
totally
Not matching the scenario, but you know
Good old quiet christian girls
Slick how well they have Megan super catholic boyfriend
I want to go to gym class
Look, it's the first day no funny guys no comedians no bringers of the ha ha, okay
This year's gym class isn't last year's gym class. We're gonna really buckle down in physical fitness. I don't know what to give the
gym teacher
I'm fit as fuck. I ain't buckling shit
Young lady. What's your name?
Nicole do you want my phone number two? This is only the first class. Nicole. You won't be no, that'll fuck up my voice if I do that
Trust out for every class don't to zero hit the locker room. See you back here in 10
No, I'ma change I hated I hated you. I remember one year
I was able to convince my mom to like not let me do gym in high school
And so I got like a year of no jam. It was great and like I'm an athletic person person person person too
Like I was very good at sports. I just
An actual jerk to give him a jersey accent. Okay, okay, okay
Where the hell did I put the shirt? Why does it even need the school logo? Just bring my own shitty shirts
Oh, no having trouble no wait. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on
Having trouble Nicole saw you a lagging behind thought you might need a spare shirt. Oh, thanks. Stop looking now please
You know something you feisty. I like that in my female students
I got a feeling you like something else in your female students too
See he snapped back like that. I like it. It's sexy
You are saying this to a 16 year old girl in the girl's locker room
Come on. What's age? Look at you. You're mature enough
Oh
Oh choices choices, huh
Choices uh, it sounds like we're gonna humor the pedophile. I guess yeah, so
Just wanted to chat with a pretty girl about
Oh, I don't know. I just uh like looking at you
I
Girls
I'm sorry. I wanted to be I wanted to be controversial
Yeah, I'll prove it to you hang up by the back entrance and I'll pick you up after school
Oh, wait, can we go back can we go back go back go back go back
Go back
I don't want to do this. I don't like these choices
Okay, we're not dating our gym teacher
Hey, man, I'd love to catch an or but I have got homework
Oh, I guess you're right. Hey, but one day we'll make something happen. I can't let my sexiest student get away now
Oh my god, your gym club coach has been around the block, sweetie. Yeah. Well, sorry. I didn't work out
I've had less periods in states in america, but again, sorry
Did I work out?
This game is
Uh, if you're bmi's what?
Dude, shut up. Who cares? I think you're getting far with that mentality. You gotta nut up nicole
Oh, sorry. I didn't know dodgeball was a long-term goal for you
You know what if what if it's a long-term goal for me, huh?
I feel sorry for you because i'm pretty sure the camp told extreme dodgeball like two years ago
You saw that show too. That's sick. You know, you're kind of cool for a girl
I want to see my cock. Thanks. Uh, sorry. You're not a person who warrants return compliments
That's actually a good fucking line. I'm stealing that
It's kind of hot. Hey, you want to you want to what?
Wait, what did you say?
Hold on. I have to look back at my vaude because I didn't know what he said
Uh, come on. Hurry up. Hurry up self
Come on. No, I think I think I'm behind in my own vaude. I am
Okay, do I want to hang out should we hang out with him? I'm gonna I'm gonna have you guys help me with this one
Should he does he have no chance?
Because I'm gonna play through stuff. I'm not gonna save and go back because that's stupid
Kyler, please I'm begging
Nope. No, okay. Let's put it to a vote. Let's put it to a vote
Kyler yes or no
I'm gonna wait for that. I'm gonna look at see where my food is
Oh, it's heading to me
Oh, it's all the way it'll be here in 10 minutes
We stay indecisive he's the stupidest character in game. That's kind of funny grill him
Would you order? Um, I'll tell you when it gets here
Oh
My tummy is like I've literally only had applesauce. What the fuck is wrong with me?
Before you dig in snap a photo of your food. No, I'm fucking eating that shit. You kidding me door ash. I got it here
Dumb golden retriever type energy she be for
Can we put the gym teacher six feet under in facts? That's so gross for real
No, I'm gnomes. No, okay. Dipsha has no chance with me
Good night
Are you seriously asking me out while taking dodgeball seriously?
No, I mean, well, kind of it could just be sex. We don't need like a whole relationship
Oh, sorry. I don't know the politically correct way of asking this, but are you actually retarded?
I don't know who told you but when I got tested that was supposed to be a secret fucking trolley. Can't keep us
Don't clip it
Don't
Your quintessential dipshit don't fucking do it
If you do it, I'm ending the stream right now
I'm not even fucking with you
I
I'm ending it
Ended by everybody
streams done
All right
I'll see you guys around. It's been great. I'm gonna go eat some food
Uh, let's see
Oh, no, fuck you guys I'll play
I
Hate all of you
Quinn, uh, I don't know what the fuck that means, but I'm gonna kick your ass. I'm a girl. Don't fucking hurt me
Actually, no
Honestly, if I if I hit a guy, I'd totally expect him to hit me back
I beat the shit out of my mom
Get the nerd in on it. I feel like that won't matter. I don't think he'll let me
Let him simmer down. I feel like yeah, because I was mean to him. He won't do anything for me
Let's get a fucking beat up
I would I would if I if I got I would totally get the shit over a guy though
I'm a strong bitch
Okay, whatever you're the only party who cares in this anyway. Yeah, don't test me again. There's gonna be trouble now
I got balls to dodge
Why does everyone in the closet want to kill me?
What's that
What's what the gym clothes
Oh, yeah, the heat's cranked way too high here. So I just left class in this. I can finally breathe, you know
Okay, well, you're the first girl I've ever met who isn't cold 24 seven
Yep, not cold at all
I am actually
Canonically, I'm cold 24 seven. Um, I don't my customers when I worked in sales
Tell me I probably have what is it called reinoids syndrome or renaud syndrome
Because my fingers turn white
When I'm really cold
And I lose a feeling in my lens. Well, mostly my fingies
He he
He he who who
Ho ho ho he he
Hold on. Let me see where my food is at
Oh my god, please
Oh, they're so close
Don't click what don't be an asshole
That will
She be you can't eat on stream. Fuck it. We ball
A skip's changing to get out what let's throw it away. What about you?
He asked me out and I'm pretty clearly told him to screw off
It's like white guys who like running can't take no for an answer
I wish I had like five percent of your confidence. How's that confidence blatantly telling some scary dude to get lost?
I could never do that
It's not that I'm confident. I'm just too lazy to give a shit facts
True
It's either I'm too lazy or I'm too crazy
Months later
So it's been a few months since we moved to school going like academically or socially
Everything anything honestly it's going pretty good
It looks like she didn't have any arms for a second because
the
color of the background
Nothing's a burden
Yeah, I'll turn on the the audio like the voice acting stuff when um my food gets here like I'll put it like this
Anytime I got asked for my company asked me out or asked or anything
And I make decisions entirely for myself not concerned with their feelings. There's no stress
Damn, she's a bad bitch
Honey, that sounds a little mean-spirited. Don't you think?
Yeah, well, what's the alternative of being used to do shit people
Especially men are for the perfect pawns when you don't give a fuck about them or whatever they want
I won't argue as
Half the all my viewers leave because they hear me say that they're just like what she be
Because there's feminism you vote and work. Okay, well fuck feminism. I'm starting necolism
Necolism. Yeah, the main concept is girls are moving all emotional attachment from anyone
Oh, I'm sure you'll meet a nice boy soon. You'll be all over this
How can I meet a nice boy when all men are just rapists and pedophiles is fucking kids nice mom?
This conversation's over
Oh
Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god
Hold on. Let me pause. Who the fuck is this guy?
Okay, my food's here. Let me run. I'm gonna be our be real quick. Go get it. Um and come back
Let me just stretch
E
All right, see you in a moment love
You
Okay
Uh
So, you know how door dash like I'm like if someone doesn't speak English usually like auto translate
So they do this Spanish and so I think my person was Spanish and they just
They just said here I am
And I'm like, okay
And then I was gonna go to the elevator to go downstairs and then he just shows up. He's like here I am and I'm like
And it was funny he looked at me he was like, oh
Because I look like a rat right now
I look like shit. I'm wearing just wearing a pair of fucking booty shorts and a sweatshirt
My hair's a mess. I still haven't showered
Probably shower after this
Okay, let me move my keyboard
Gracias mi amor. Yeah. Hello me. I'm me. I'm your mi amor. There's no ice in here
I'm probably eliminated and put no ice in it
Shower stream one. I've already done that
Not like in a stream, but I did record myself in the shower
Okay
I've actually already forgot what I got
I got
Sandwich so it's a mac and cheese chicken sandwich
Then I got what is this? Oh, it's sauce boomie. Can you fuck off dude? You don't have boomie is
One of those cats that oh, I need to lock my door. What is this? Oh, it's marinara sauce
um
Boomie's one of those cats that just like has to be a part of everything
Door locks
And then I also got some
Sammy spicy no, it's like kind of spicy
It's not this it's not the spicy one. It's the mac and cheese
What is this?
Oh, this is I'm definitely gonna have a lot of leftovers. Um
It's like mozzarella sticks
But they're made with ontons
Oh
Blooming I'm gonna fight you
And then I have some tater tots with parmesan
One bite
Boomi's literally looking at me and looking at his lips. Boomi likes french fries. He steals french fries from me
There was no three, what are you talking about? I should probably have a napkin here
Cause I'm probably gonna spill something in myself. Oh, I'll just use this blanket
This is a towel, right blanket
If three gang ever emerges, what is this random role play going on?
Mmm, that's so good
I'm probably going to have the worst stomach ache later from all this cheese
Cute bunny, hello
Hey guys having fun rp-ing in the chat game of thrones house one and house two and the unknown house house three
I have lactate. I just didn't take any because I'm dumb
Are you lactose intolerance? Yeah
Well, this is the the mozzarella stick. I'll take a bite of the um, I'll take a picture of the sandwich so you guys can see what I'm eating
Wait
Now my phone is using to being used to record. Never mind. You can't see
I
I get diarrhea when I drink chocolate milk nobody asked
But only chocolate milk. I don't think you should drink chocolate milk then bro
I I'm not the one who lactates that is a zura
Lactosians, what are you talking about?
Hope you'll be all right after all the cheese you're consuming. I'll probably die later
I'm probably fight for my life on the toilet later. No worries
You could at least try
What?
What's going on here? That's what I'm asking. That's what I'm asking bro. What is going on here?
She's 56. Can she still lactate? Yep
Okay, let me take a bite of the sandwich. Oh my god, it looks so fucking good
Oh my god, oh the spicy fuck. Oh no. Yeah, I'm not gonna have a fun time later
I
Looks so funny when I eat food
When I drink something
Um, oh my god, spicy. No, I forgot it was spicy
So what it is it's a nap. Yeah, just say it's a garlic mac and cheese
Um
On it like a on a chicken fried chicken sandwich
Pretty bomb
No two one but one also technically one because two was spicy and I forgot it was
Well, it's just a bun, you know, it's just a bun then the fried chicken then a little bit of mac and cheese and then that
So was the hidden third option
I need a bar. Oh my god, boomi. What are you doing?
brother
brother, what are you doing?
Why are you playing the paper clip?
boomi
Are you serious?
Why? Oh my god, he's a menace in society. I need a burp
I hid it from you. You don't deserve my burps
I need to take off my shirt. I'm getting hot. Oh my god a bird just flew really close by my window
Two gang is just a palm. Okay, let's let's watch tv
While I eat
Could you lock your door? I did lock my door. Why are you knocking on it? I'm gonna come visit
Wait, can I go back?
Okay
Couple months later
Oh
I
Feel like the he can't tell you what to do will cause him to probably like send me to the principal's office
Passive aggressive eye roll
Mr. White can get it on guys that his name mr. White
You trust my instincts
I'm gonna be a bitch
How dare you how dare you disrupt my lecture. It's disrespectful to me and your classmates
You can't trick anyone here. Is he Walter white when no one gives a shit about your class in the first place
Well, how would you like a failing grade? How would all of you like a failing grade?
Yeah, the girl to the right is kind of hot
Yeah, mr. White, you can't keep us from graduating you tell him the call. Yeah, you tell him
You finger skateboard bitch. Oh, I was just trying to help. Yeah, you were trying something
I can visit to the counselor's office the principal's office
Hey, if you think not listening to you talk is disciplined, then I'm gone. No problem
out
Again, Nicole. Oh, not the counselor. Every time you said a lot of stuff so I can leave early
The principal ordered for you to be in this room for one hour
I like how the principal's purse is like in the chair. You'll see them slapping the shit on
And what do you mean by that?
How are you feeling? I'm saying if a whole company like them can't get my order, right?
Then what's one guy like you? Mistakes happen. They can try again after the next soccer practice
I think we go to Mr. White supremacist. Wait, what?
I fucking derailed this shit talking out of turn in class bullying classmates talking back to faculty
Is this really are you gonna kill me? Why am I leaving behind a legacy?
It's high school who gives a shit fact
Show some light on everyone else. Hmm like I would just like tell him off like about what everybody else does
Probably about the gym teacher. It's high school. I'm gonna do that
Say that to all the guys who go here. It's like a co-ed prison without tattoos
Do you think it's a tad irresponsible to point fingers at others when you're the one in question here
Aren't you mr. Child psychologist like trauma and all that shapes who we are?
Well, yes, I have several degrees in pediatric psychology
What's your point every dude here is like a rapist or a drug addict or trying to turn you into a drug addict
Have you tried something? What are you doing? I understand you not try to play in my wires
I just feel like you're gonna shut off my computer. He's like real cold on
teacher or
No, no, no get shoot
He was like dangerously close
to
My power outlet where like the switch would just turn off everything. So if I disappear
In stream just dies. That is the reason why boomie. What is the matter mr?
Why don't you go play with fia?
Hi
It's important. What's wrong? Okay, let me go get him a toy to play with
I have the pee
Okay, let me pee and get him a toy
You
All right, can you bitch just stop warping in the chat for the love of god the joke is done
I was making the shiba aid. Oh, it's pretty good
real quick
You might hear like some noises in the background because I gave my cats their toys so that they'll play
Reina's sleeping nicely by my feet because she is a good old lady
at the ripe age of 14
and then
Boomi and fia are fucking about in my closet playing with a spring toy
Teachers are trying to fuck me too. You're all psychotic a few months ago
Mr. Burlodey was really feeling up one of my friends and just last week
The coach was staring down my shirt during push-up tests
I tried to level with all my students. So can you really blame him? They really like that spring toy
That's your favorite toy
Low cut here
Go on honestly her outfit is fine. We're looking away the entire time you've been here. Oh my god. That's so fucked
Are you kidding me right now? Where's the hidden camera? What show is this?
You're like acting for a prank show, right? I'm waiting for someone more attractive than you to walk in so I can pretend to laugh
Nicole there's no prank here. Oh, so you're just seriously a pedophile
He's right here. Did we ever have our little chat on social constructs? I'm leaving
Oh my fucking god
So fuck photography. Yeah pretty much mr. White acts like his class is so goddamn important
We can take pictures with a camera phone who even needs a camera camera anymore
Exactly message electives get so insecure when they realize they can't stop anyone from graduating
It'd be happy anyone even took your class. It's an art course. Anyway, I like doing your makeups a huge step down
What's up you whores? Wow
I'm gonna spit on my drink
What do you want all right damn hold on you shit. Wow. What's up you whores?
That's actually me when I enter any sort of call. Oh my god, the sandwich is so fucking spicy
with the girls
That's how I walk in the call
What's up you whores
I heard something fall. I think my cats are oh my god. I'm dying. Okay, so I'm drooling. Oh my god. This is so fucking
Oh, why is it so spicy?
I can't I can't
I
Oh my god
I swear to god the sandwich is not spicy. Why is this spicy now? Should I accidentally click spicy in my order?
I remember
No, I'm really fighting for my life
I can't I can't handle spice I get that from my mom actually know my mom can handle spice and soak in my dad
So I don't even know why I can't handle spice
Oh my god, the burp is like sucking my fucking throat
Well, I just got lightheaded
I
Let me go get some milk and then I'm gonna go on a live myself in Minecraft
I'm dying
It's not supposed to parts
I just bought it though. Oh, yeah, it's fine
Oh
Oh my god, you got your spring
Okay, yeah, I've only taken like a few bites of that sandwich and I think I'm done
I
Need some milk
The cats are just walking around playing with their toys boomies playing in a plastic bag. What's his spring?
Can I have it? Can you can you what my sandwich? No
I'm throwing that motherfucker in the air fryer tomorrow tomorrow. I'm gonna fight for my life tomorrow too actually
Oh my god, I can't stop hiccuping
Oh my god, there's so much spit in my mouth
I can blow bubbles
I just drooled
So how are you guys doing you having fun I'm enjoying myself I think
I feel like I got punched in the stomach. Oh, it's fine. The spice must flow fears the mind to live
Those movies are good actually
All right, dude was good book. Actually, no, I didn't end up. Did I finish dude? Did I finish reading dude?
I don't think I did. I think I got like halfway
Streams can be a criminal stream's been a criminal disaster in all the best weas
Or just ball
Barbie wish you be I'm playing Hades too. Oh, I want to play Hades
How I said I would like it. I'm still panting
Dune books get weird. I know a spot. Yeah, I don't have a spice dollars
My ethnicity failed me
And I'm like
My white mother could handle spice way better than me
Well, you know what I blame my mom because apparently I don't know why I'm talking like this
You know, I'm not talking like Cartman
but um
But it's the only way I can feel like
My mouth is okay. Um, so my mom when she was pregnant with me
Only a bottle of chicken wings because I was there like grave
So I think because of all the spicy food. I just can't handle spicy food
I don't know
Hades is goaded
Crazy respect my authority
You might hear Fia meowing in the background because she gets really excited when she plays and she starts meowing at herself
Little girl, what are you doing?
This is our scoff to madam. It's me
Don't think I don't spin in your fucking eyes
I
Just because you guys are shitting on me so much
Yeah, if you hear that little like chat like noise in the background, that's um, I'm playing with the springs on my
Good god, I'm lifting up your glasses. I'm spitting in your face right in the eyes
I'm at seven point. What the fuck are you serious?
I'm at seven point two k on twitter
You
You're joking you're joking you gotta be joking you're fucking with me aren't you
Bro, what the fuck
Why the fuck
Do I have
Seven point two k on my alt account
What
I
So like so the reason I I'm blowing up is so mercy um posted a thing in
Use the word uh p o r n in it
In the tweet
And so then her tweet blew up to like three k likes and I'm like, oh fuck it. Let me try
And I'm like I was like ha ha this account has p o r n
And then no, I fucking seven thousand followers
Like I can't breathe. What the fuck?
Why can't it be my main account my main account is three k less
Oh sex sex sexes sales
You know twitter's blasting horny. Yeah, it literally is though
Oh, I actually I'm also more active on my alt because I try to keep my um
Uh thing professional just say the p word on your mean I
I could be like hey guys go follow my alt. That's where all the p o r n is
Actually experiment let's do it
Yeah
Live tweeting
I forgot to say I was
I forgot to say I was live
I always forget to tweet that I'm live
I'm gonna have to start how your management tweet for me and be like saying when I'm live
It's been three hours
Oh, my neighbor probably helped hates me because I've been yelling a bunch. Actually, I don't even know if they're home
Testing it
Okay, let me move my food that I'm not going to be able to finish to the side because I am dying
I barely even ate anything. I literally only ate like a couple mozzarella sticks
And that's what I ate and some tater dots. You know if you buy somebody so much
um
Because my alt is blowing up for no reason
I am going to
Mess with the algorithm
here
And say something about porn
Why is twitter pushing porn, I don't know
Also follow my alt
At she be
And
You gotta you gotta play the game you gotta you gotta play the stonks, you know, I'm still dying
Because uh twitter likes that word now
Oh my god, my tummy is rumbling bad
All right
Oh, no, actually they banned it for a little bit
Oh
Guys, I think I think getting this food was a bad idea. I don't feel so good
I
Mean dummy heart
Sorry
My high pitch voice comes out when I mean they should be excited or super fucked up
I'm not the sub
You're the sub you're the sub you're the sub I'm mad I'm
Even with my cunny voice you're still the sub. You're still a fucking
Okay
Yeah, fucking subs I'll make you feel way worse
Mess their spit on the floor then clean it up use your use your tongue
Even when my my even when my cunny voice you're still a sub so get on your knees
I like my spit off the floor
Like a good little puppy
Fucking prick fucking hell fucking dumb asses bitches. I hate you all
No, you should talk and mr. White. Yeah, he probably deserves it
What do you want? All right, damn. Did you guys get an invite to kelly's poll party poll party?
No, her parents are like really rich. It's glass and and everything. It's kind of actually fucking cool
They got those four foot long syringe water gun things. What are you 10? Whatever
I've been here for a year and never once heard of someone having sex with you
I've been here since third grade and haven't heard it. No, uh, remember freshman year with jenny philmore
She was unconscious. How do you still brag?
That's so fast like the reason they have women's college. Okay old news. Whatever you have invites or not
Yeah, let me too. How did you get one? You haven't even been here
Because i'm a cool ass bitch. That's why I'm not fat facts. Okay. Well, like her belts
I used to have belts like that if I can't go. I don't want to be responsible for you ruining the party
But I also want to listen. I'm a tomboy. I really like boys
Nicole's choice fine
Nicole, I know I think I'm getting better, but could you let me go with you just this once?
I've worn
I've worn three belts at once
three belts
With this this voice sounds better when I put this little mouth on
Yeah
Choose the top
Well, yeah, I was planning on it
Yeah, no, fuck off fine. Be a bitch. See if I care you're just mad. You can't see us in bikinis this weekend
What are you doing? What don't get flustered like that. He's a rapist sex turns
Rapist right to those types. What like choking and biting that and jerking off while thinking about us suddenly turning into
Jekyll would look so hot with her organs gouged out. Hell. Yeah. How do you know these things?
I had a brother. You had up. Is he dead?
Did you fucking kill your brother? Are you wearing to Kelly's pool party? Well summer's over. So no, we're selling anything
Hello girls. Oh fucking this guy again
Pool party in the fall? Yeah. Well, I don't know Jeffery mode. My place is Jeffery mode. I could help you out with that
You sell bikinis? Of course not. But swing by my office later and we can take some measurements for the homex sewing club
Oh my god, this guy creeps me out so bad
To your every curve. Gee. Thanks. I'll see you there. Maybe have a good day at school
Yes, I know her brother's fucking alive. It was a fucking rhetorical question. You idiots
What are you guys freaking out about? I think the counselor might have made an advance at me
They're made in advance. Who says that?
Yawn, what else is new? What? You've gone here longer than me. How did you not notice? To be fair, he's kind of subtle about it
He's what I call a marathon pedophile
Sorry, but what the fuck is a marathon? Fuck, I got a toot. He tries to make you question society's hatred of pedophilia before he actually
molests you then you'll feel bad. That's actually really fucked up. So he guilt you so he can make a routine out of it
Exactly a predator. Are you the same age as the count? Is the counselor 56?
That's like three levels worse than what I thought he was gonna do. I don't know. Why do you even want to measure you anyway?
For bikini to wear a killie's pool party. He'd have home ec make it home ec. What are they gonna make a fucking felt bathing?
Yeah, I was like, how are you gonna make anything?
Okay, I think I'm good. I think it's yeah
You planned on swimming at a pool party. What do you do at a pool party sit around and look cute same?
Yeah, that's yeah
Never been to a pool party, but sure
The school saw no one steals shit anyway. You still aren't dressed. Yeah, they need thumbprint scanners or some shit
It's 2008. Isn't it the future by now? You're gonna be late. No shit
Now how many spends again? Oh wait, hold on. Nailed it. What the fuck?
There's no lock on the doors saw it as a great opportunity
Choke him out if that happened to me. I'm sorry. Do you think you're cool right now?
You're a freak not even the sex being counselor wants to fuck you your petty insults will make the development of this photograph
All the more satisfying
Cam girls are all cheap digital nonsense. I've captured your I'm cheap digital nonsense. That's me
I'm cheap digital nonsense
Yeah, if you're gonna sexually harass me could you not talk like a cartoon character while you do it
I do what I want with my words
I'll also do as I please with this photo. No, come on. Just throw the film out. I'm afraid I can't do that
Every boy with a crush on you should pay top dollar for these prints. That I would literally kill him
No, I should have been nice to him. Oh, no
You won't convince me otherwise runs away. Wait, was I at the wrong locker? Oh my god, you're all really
I need a lock on that door. Thanks hindsight. So what the fuck do I do right now?
This is gonna ruin my life. Well, technically isn't that like
Child pornography if it takes a picture and tries to spread it has a picture of my titties halfway out
Yeah, they'll probably find a way to make it your fault. Anyway, I still can't believe he shot it on medium format film of all
Look, I'm just worried about the print the film type parents in the 70s. Wait, like film film
Like it needs to be Jeffrey's Jeffrey's a very nice guy up to tomorrow's film club
That bitch no lab. No developing if it's some weird format. There won't be another one for miles and miles, right?
Destroying the dark room
But I get expelled for that if you go in after everybody leaves no one needs to know
Just wear gloves or something so you don't leave finger. Oh smart
If I have any very smart. No, it's not my ass on film. Come on. I'd help if it was you
No, you wouldn't
Okay, I wouldn't but
God damn it
Is it really the end of the world if people see you in your underwear? You look good naked
Yeah, exactly if I had weird tits and a gut it'd be classified as an artistic nude
But if you're hot with no clothes on it's porn
Fine, I'll drive you over there, but I'm not stepping a foot inside artistic anew. Let's go
Wow, I am creative when it comes to destroying things
Are you done yet?
Yeah, set it on fire. This should buy me enough time to swipe Jeffrey's camera and ruin the negative
Hey, do you have permission to-
Why is there a cop?
Uh
If I said a teacher told me to meet here for a date
Would you go after him or just blame me for that too a date in your pajamas?
Did he tell you to destroy thousands in school property too? Look at this place come with me. What it was like this when I
Sleep walked in here
You wear gloves to bed
Yeah, don't you?
Well, so much for jack a stupid fucking glove idea to this day
I genuinely believe sleepwalking would have worked if it wasn't for wearing those
Anyway, I got statewide expulsion. Yeah, I didn't know it was a thingy. Oh, no, that sucks
I'm used to move again
Forced me to get a shitty job and hits me to relieve her feelings of disappointment
The deep fryer leaving craters on my face. No, I don't like this ending
Is a suicidal experience
Wow, the camera really does add 10 pounds fuck off
No
What the one the other mouth on I look way too devilish I look normal fun like this when I'm like
I'm just gonna look at you
I'm so disappointed in myself. I'm not even joking. Yeah, there's no stream. I took a break today
Uh, love you all. Let's uh find someone to read
I will simply pass away
Can I please read her eyes, please?
Oh, at least there's only like 300 of you watching
Oh god, I've given myself a headache. Let's see who's live right now
Because I'm like, oh, I can't wait to make nobody's gonna want to be friends with me
And like a man and a
Because I was hoping to raid someone outside the jet my
My gen to my company today, but I'm not gonna send all you
depraved idiots to some poor person
I'm just gonna send you to straw nation. I don't know how to handle you and
I already know you're gonna tell on me
Whatever do your worst
You just won't get nice Maros for a week. Hmm. I won't say zero. Hmm. Hmm
Hmm
Well
I'm gonna go, uh
Cry into my pillow and uh, I'll fuck my voice. Uh pretend that um
Can't
I'm gonna go cry into my pillow and
Regret all my life choices
I'm not right. No, I'm not
I am not
I am not racist, please
Please
I
Fuck my life why you guys still smell bad jesus christ stinky
You